la séance est ouverte
l'ordre du jour appelle la discussion
après engagement de la procédure
accélérée du projet loi adopté par le
Sénat relatif à l'accélération des
procédures liées à la construction de
nouvelles installations nucléaires à
proximité de sites nucléaires existants
et au fonctionnement des installations
existantes la parole est à Madame Agnès
panier rue nacher ministre de la
transition énergétique
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente
messieurs les présidents de commissions
mais
mesdames les rapporteurs mesdames et
messieurs les députés
après la promulgation samedi de la loi
relative à l'accélération de la
production des énergies renouvelables
voici venu le temps de vous prononcer
sur le deuxième pilier de la stratégie
de transition énergétique conduite par
le gouvernement la relance de notre
filière nucléaire ces deux textes ont un
point commun celui de répondre à une
seule et même ambitieux faire de la
France le premier grand pays industriel
à sortir de sa dépendance aux énergies
fossiles faire en sorte également
d'avoir la main sur notre destin
énergétique cette ambition elle doit
être notre seule boussole et guider
notre action dans la période difficile
que vivent nos concitoyens celle d'une
crise énergétique qui tire ses origines
d'un conflit aux portes de l'Europe
celle d'une crise climatique qui a
provoqué des mégafeux des inondations
des sécheresses et des records de
chaleur cet été et qui menacent déjà
l'été à venir
mesdames et messieurs les députés mettre
fin à l'utilisation du gaz du pétrole et
du charbon voilà le combat de notre
siècle c'est le seul combat qui vaille
tant pour des raisons climatiques et de
concorde social que pour des raisons
d'indépendance économiques et donc
politique c'est le seul combat qui
vaille pour remplacer les deux tiers
d'énergie fossile dans notre mix
énergétique en énergie décarbonée ce
combat il doit reposer sur la science et
ne doit pas laisser la place à la
croyance ou à l'idéologie dogmatique il
ne doit laisser aucune classe à ceux qui
veulent nous entraîner dans l'opposition
stériles des énergies renouvelables
contre l'énergie nucléaire
ce combat il n'est ni de droite ni de
gauche il est le combat de notre temps
le temps de l'écologie maîtriser nos
émissions de gaz à effet de serre et le
combat de l'écologie de ce siècle
accélérer les énergies renouvelables
c'est être écologiste relancer notre
filière nucléaire c'est être écologique
car comment se dit écologiste en
préférant les énergies fossiles aux
énergies décarbonées comment se dire
écologiste lorsque l'on ne vote pas le
texte de loi qui accélère le déploiement
des énergies renouvelables lorsque l'on
répète adnozéames que le nucléaire émet
plus de carbone que l'éolien ou le
photovoltaïque lorsque l'on vante le
modèle allemand qui repose sur le
charbon lorsqu'on refuse les conclusions
des experts du GIEC et du Haut Conseil
pour le climat qui souligne que le
nucléaire est un olivier pour lutter
contre le réchauffement climatique
lorsqu'on parle d'énergie la culture
scientifique doit être entendue et c'est
bien sur la science que ça puis la
stratégie énergétique du président de la
République énoncé à Belfort elle repose
sur trois indissociables piliers que
nous mettons en œuvre avec la première
ministre et la majorité d'une part la
réduction de la consommation d'énergie
qui passe par la sobriété l'efficacité
énergétique si nous voulons atteindre la
neutralité carbone les experts de RTE
nous le disent nous devrons réduire de
40% notre consommation d'énergie à
horizon 2050 le plan de sobriété que
j'ai présenté en octobre dernier et la
première brique de cette trajectoire de
long terme grâce à la mobilisation des
grandes entreprises des grandes
collectivités des grandes
administrations et plus largement des
Françaises et des Français ce plan a
permis à notre pays de réduire de 10% sa
consommation de gaz et d'électricité
combiner cet hiver c'est à dire
l'équivalent de la production de cette
réacteurs nous avons ainsi su faire en
trois mois ce que d'autres pays en dépit
de certaines lois n'a pas su faire en 30
ans d'autre part notre stratégie
énergétique repose sur l'augmentation
massive et durable de notre production
d'énergie décarbonée je l'ai dit nous
n'avons pas le luxe du dogmatisme nous
devons accélérer la production de toutes
les énergies décarbonées disponibles dès
lors qu'elles sont compatibles avec
notre indépendance énergétique et
qu'elle contribue à fournir à nos
concitoyens une énergie abondante et
abordable notre stratégie implique donc
de développer massivement les énergies
renouvelables et de relancer l'énergie
nucléaire et sur ce point assumons de le
dire sans dix tour oui notre pays a un
lien historique avec la technologie
nucléaire oui ce lien est le fruit d'une
volonté politique forte et ambitieuse
celle du général de Gaulle et de ses
successeurs c'est bien dans cet héritage
politique que s'inscrit le programme de
relance porté par le Président de la
République
des activistes comme zione ancienne
figure d'extinction rébellion au Greta
Thunberg reconnaissent l'importance du
nucléaire pour sortir des énergies
fossiles des personnalités politiques
comme Alexandria
occasion Cortes vente la filière du
recyclage nucléaire françaises plus de
75% des Français se disent favorables à
la relance du nucléaire et l'adhésion au
nucléaire est plus forte encore chez les
citoyens qui habitent à proximité des
réacteurs des partenaires européens
affichent désormais une stratégie
similaire à la nôtre la Suède les
Pays-Bas la Belgique la République
tchèque ou encore la Roumanie pour ne
citer que cela on manifesté leur souhait
de se doter de nouvelles capacités de
production nucléaire ou de prolonger
l'utilisation de leur capacités
nucléaires existantes j'ai d'ailleurs
lancé avec 11 de mes homologues
européens une alliance européenne du
nucléaire pour renforcer nos
coopérations et conforter notre autonom
stratégique dans ce domaine une alliance
qui vise à défendre la contribution du
nucléaire à nos objectifs climatiques il
y a la sécurité énergétique de notre
continent c'est absolument stratégique
car l'avenir du nucléaire se joue aussi
au niveau européen nous avons remporté
une première bataille sur la taxonomie
européenne et nous devons remporter la
deuxième qui se joue cette semaine avec
la proposition de règlement sur
l'industrie 0 carbone vous pouvez
compter sur ma détermination pour porter
ses positions auprès de mes homologues
avec ce projet de loi que j'ai l'honneur
de vous présenter aujourd'hui notre
objectif est d'anticiper et d'être prêt
si nous décidions après les
concertations les débats publics et les
débats parlementaires qui s'imposent
d'avancer sur le programme de nouveaux
nucléaires français cela s'inscrit dans
la droite ligne de notre action depuis
le début du premier quinquennat commande
dès 2018 à EDF d'une étude sur un
nouveau programme nucléaire commande en
2019 à RTU d'une étude sur notre futur
énergétique mobilisation des filières de
l'amont à Laval avec le plan de relance
et le plan France 2030 concertation sur
notre mix énergétique d'états publics
sur les nouveaux réacteurs sous l'égide
de la CNDP Conseil de politique
nucléaire sous l'égide du président de
la République tout est fait avec ordre
et dans l'ordre pour que la décision
définitive que nous prenons soit la plus
éclairée la plus concertée et la plus
préparée possible
entendu de nombreuses approximations
lors de nos débats en commission des
affaires économiques il est d'abord
inexact et malhonnête de prétendre que
le gouvernement engendrait le débat
public avec ce projet de loi les deux
débats publics celui de la programmation
plus réelle de l'énergie et celui de la
construction de nouveaux réacteurs
repères de ce sont déroulés sous l'égide
de la CNDP et ils sont maintenant
achevés j'avais d'ailleurs
personnellement qu'on vivait chacun des
commissaires aux affaires économiques et
au développement durable à la conclusion
de la concertation sur le mex
énergétique à l'occasion d'un forum qui
a réuni 200 jeunes tirés au sort dans la
France je note que pas un seul député
qui pourtant ne cesse de réclamer du
débat public sur ses bancs nous a fait
l'honneur de sa présence je ne parle pas
des députés de la majorité qui étaient
présents notamment monsieur le Président
des questions sont posées par les
participants sur la technologie
nucléaire la plus pertinente les coûts
du programme la gestion des déchets et
la disponibilité des compétences nous
devons leur apporter des réponses il
nous y travaillons c'est notre
responsabilité c'est pourquoi j'ai lancé
une revue du nouveau programme nucléaire
qui nous permettra d'avoir d'ici la
finalité les coûts actualisés une
évaluation des choix technologiques un
état des lieux industriels de la filière
et un point sur les besoins de
compétences mais nous avançons d'avoir
mais nous assumons d'avoir un projet de
relance du nucléaire car précisément la
raison d'un débat public c'est de
débattre d'un projet clairement
identifié ce texte au-delà de son
caractère technique porte notre ambition
politique pour cette filière celle d'une
grande aventure scientifique
industrielle et humaine qui va
rassembler des hommes et des femmes des
industries et des savoir-faire au
service d'un projet national stratégique
un projet pour renouer avec l'esprit de
la France des bâtisseurs un projet pour
la fierté de notre pays et que je peux
témoigner que c'était bien de la fierté
que j'ai vu dans les yeux des salariés
du site de framatum des jeunes en
formation grâce aux bourses d'études
lancées dans le cadre du Plan France
relance lorsque j'ai annoncé la
relocalisation au Creusot d'un nouvel
atelier industriel pour la fabrication
de pièces critiques de futur réacteurs
avec ce texte n'est plus ni moins le fil
de la plus grande aventure industrielle
française depuis les années 70 que nous
renouons c'est une brique technique au
service d'une ambition politique assumée
l'adoption des plus de 170 amendements
en commission ont permis d'améliorer la
rédaction du texte tout en maintenant
son objectif rendre nos procédures plus
efficaces je tiens à remercier à
remercier les rapporteurs mode région et
Christine Decotte ainsi que les
présidents Guillaume Kasparian et
Jean-Marc zulesi pour leur travail
précieux sur ce texte ce travail en
commission a permis de retirer du texte
tous les objectifs programmatiques qui
n'ont pas leur place ici la position du
gouvernement est très claire ni plancher
ni plafond nous devons envoyer un signal
à notre filière qui a trop longtemps
souffert d'injonctions contradictoires
ces objectifs programmatiques seront
discutés dans les prochains mois dans le
cadre de l'examen de la première loi de
programmation énergie climat ce texte
permet également plus de sûreté je vais
être très clair et très ferme sur ce
point l'accélération ne se fera pas au
détriment de la sûreté de nos
installations présentes et circule ce
projet de loi ne touche pas une seule
virgule contrairement à ce qu'on peut
entendre de nos procédures de sûreté
nucléaire à un moment où la charge de
travail va devenir croissante il est
proposé d'élargir les missions de
l'Autorité de sûreté nucléaire qui peut
être contre de réunir à la manière du
Canada ou encore des États-Unis les
compétences de l'IRSN et celles de la SN
sous le statut protecteur d'autorité
administrative indépendante voilà la
réalité de ce projet l'assen sera ainsi
la deuxième autorité de sûreté au monde
en termes de moyens humains et
financiers avec une crédibilité
scientifique que je souhaite total et je
trouve totalement légitime que le
Parlement renforce le contrôle du
Parlement et de l'OPEX sur le
gouvernement dans la conduite de la
réforme en ce sens je serai favorable
aux porté par le groupe modem et le
député Jean-Luc fujit qui vont dans ce
sens il leur faudra aussi permettre de
garantir la ligne que j'ai fixée sur la
transparence de notre système de
sécurité avec un amendement du groupe
Renaissance et de la rapporteur ou
encore renforcer l'attractivité des
métiers si c'est possible avec un
amendement que nous souhaitons sur le
recrutement des personnels de recherche
puisqu'il a été déclaré et recevable
malheureusement ce texte est donc le
deuxième texte énergétique soumis au
Parlement en trois mois ce qui témoigne
de notre détermination avec la majorité
de construire ensemble l'avenir
énergétique de notre pays de notre
détermination à mettre fin à notre
dépendance aux énergies fossiles
vis-à-vis de puissance étrangères
parfois hostile grâce à la productions
d'énergie décarbonée sur notre
territoire de notre détermination
collective avec la majorité à répondre
aux enjeux de pouvoir d'achat des
Français et de compétitivité de nos
entreprises et enfin de notre
détermination avec la majorité à faire
de notre pays un grand pays énergétique
souverain sur ces technologies est
capable de les exporter car la France
j'en ai la conviction profonde est une
grande nation nucléaire je vous remercie
la parole est à Madame Maud Bregeon
rapporteur de la commission des affaires
économiques
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des affaires économiques
chers collègues
il y a un peu plus d'un an le discours
de Belfort du président de la République
dressait les ambitions de la majorité
présidentielle en matière de nucléaire
l'heure est venue de concrétiser
ensemble et en acte ces engagements
l'objectif est simple accélérer la
relance du nucléaire et la construction
de nouveaux réacteurs sans faire aucun
compromis sur la sûreté avec ce texte
nous assumons pleinement notre ambition
pour cette filière là où d'autres
voudraient en sortir à tout prix et je
commencerai par là
nous supprimons enfin le plafond qui
limite la part du nucléaire à 50% dans
le mix électrique et la limite de
capacité installées deux dispositions
introduites sous le quinquennat de
François Hollande pour affaiblir la
filière sur la base de considération
idéologique et sur fond d'accord
politiciens avec les vers pourtant le
nucléaire est une part de notre histoire
nationale qu'aucun président de la 5ème
république de droite comme de gauche
n'avait alors remis en cause chacun et
c'est tout à leur honneur avait préservé
ce fleuron industriel et le consensus
national qui l'entourait
c'est dans un contexte assez similaire à
aujourd'hui avec des prix de l'énergie
qui s'envolent des besoins majeurs
d'électrification assouvir et des choix
industriels forts qu'il y a environ 50
ans la France prenait ce virage le 6
mars 1974 Pierre Messmer annonçait au
20h de l'ORTF la construction du parc
électronucléaire ce même parc produit
encore aujourd'hui près de 70% de notre
électricité
pourtant et j'en ai bien conscience on
touche là à un sujet qui suscite des
positions très antagonistes que je peux
parfois comprendre et que je respecte à
condition qu'il s'appuie sur des
arguments fondés et étayés mais comment
ne pas déplorer que j'ai certains peu à
peu les croyances et pris le pas sur la
science force est de constater que
parfois tous les arguments sont bons peu
importe les fêtes tant qu'il servent le
dogme anti-nucléaire pourtant notre
politique énergétique et écologique doit
répondre à des considérations objectives
l'impact de la sortie du nucléaire nous
la connaissons et les résultats sont
sans appel il suffit d'observer nos
voisins il reste en Allemagne 40
gigawatts de charbon soit l'équivalent
des deux tiers de notre parc nucléaire
et nos voisins ont annoncé la semaine
dernière le doublement de leurs
capacités en gaz avec des impacts sur le
climat évident
ma conviction et j'ai déjà eu l'occasion
de le dire c'est que les vrais
écologistes aujourd'hui sont trop
nucléaires les Français ont d'ailleurs
bien compris puisque dans une large
majorité il soutiennent désormais cette
énergie
avec le soleil l'éolien sur terre comme
en mer l'hydraulique et le développement
des capacités en step notamment toutes
sont nécessaires pour relever le défi du
climat alors que les énergies refossiles
représentent 60% de l'énergie consommée
en France 85% dans le monde s'opposer au
développement de l'une d'entre elles
seraient incohérent et irresponsable
pour en revenir au coeur technique du
projet de loi la première partie du
texte crée des dispositions temporaires
pour accélérer le renouvellement de
notre parc historique si certains dont
délais sont évidemment justifiés tels
que l'instruction l'autorisation de
création sur laquelle nous ne revenons
pas d'autres peuvent être résorbées
cette construction est doublement
encadrée à l'article premier
d'une part dans l'espace ces
dispositions ne valant que pour les
réacteurs installés à proximité
d'installation existantes et d'autre
part dans le temps puisque ces mesures
ne seront applicables que pour une durée
limitée de 20 ans
durée pour laquelle nous nous sommes
accordés avec le Sénat comme dans
d'autres secteurs nous avons depuis
plusieurs années sur additionné les
contraintes administratives et
juridiques il est donc temps de se
donner les moyens de nos ambitions à
titre d'exemple l'article de accélère la
processus la procédure de mise en
compatibilité de documents d'urbanisme
avec les projets de construction tout en
associant les collectivités l'article 3
intègre le contrôle de la conformité aux
règles d'urbanisme des nouveaux
réacteurs à l'autorisation
environnementale permettant ainsi de
supprimer l'étape des autorisations
d'urbanisme au profit d'un contrôle
global et rigoureux par l'autorité
environnementale
l'article 4 est d'une est une des
dispositions les plus importantes du
texte et permet de débuter les travaux
hors ilonucléaire dès la délivrance de
l'autorisation environnementale si une
anticipation qui ne concerne pas le cœur
de l'installation et les systèmes de
sûreté mais qui permettra aux mètres
d'ouvrages de prendre de l'avance sur
certaines étapes du chemin critique du
planning et donc de les limiter les
risques de retard en cascade
la seconde partie du projet de loi porte
quant à elle sur des installations
nucléaires existantes et intègrent en
fait ni plus ni moins que des mesures de
bon sens je pense notamment à l'article
10 qui supprime la mise à l'arrêt
automatique d'une installation nucléaire
de base lorsqu'elle n'a pas fonctionné
depuis plus de 2 ans il n'y a pas de
sens est-ce que l'arrêt soit automatique
alors même que la volonté de redémarrer
par l'exploitant et bien là et que
simplement il peut y avoir des incidents
qui nécessitent d'allonger les durées
d'arrêt on a des exemples à budget comme
appel ce n'est pas au gouvernement quel
qu'il soit de juger de la sûreté d'une
installation et de sa capacité à
produire en fonctionnement normal
enfin nous allons évidemment avoir le
débat sur le rapprochement de la scène
et de l'IRSN à la suite des amendements
du Gouvernement que nous avons voté en
commission j'entends les interrogations
légitimes d'une partie de cet assemblée
nous y avons répondu en commission et
nous continuerons à le faire dans cette
hémicycle qu'est-il proposé simplement
de réunir des compétences essentielles à
la sûreté au sein d'une autorité
indépendante ce qui n'est pas le cas de
l'IRSN aujourd'hui
j'ajouterai à cela
et je l'ai beaucoup dit en commission
qu'aucun grief ne peut être fait à la SN
sur sa gestion rigoureuse de la sûreté
depuis des années elle a démontré que la
sûreté primait surtout le reste
production compris notamment lorsqu'il
s'agit d'exiger la mise à l'arrêt
temporaire de réacteurs avec parfois des
impacts sur l'équilibre du réseau ou sur
les prix de marché les exemples ne
manquent pas renforcement de la digue du
Tricastin exigence sismique à Cruas
traitement de la ségrégation sur le parc
en 2019 portage du niveau de sûreté des
réacteurs de deuxième génération au plus
près de ceux de troisième génération
l'effet parle de même
mes exigences on en parlera après mais
exigences tant comme rapporteur que
comme ancienne ingénieur du secteur
demeurent changer faire ce qu'il y a de
mieux pour garantir une filière
indépendante de sûreté d'excellence et
c'est précisément ce que prévoit la
réforme enfin et comme j'ai l'habitude
de le faire comme je m'exprime sur le
sujet je terminerai en disant qu'une
stratégie énergétique ne se résume pas à
des mégawatts et à des règles
d'exploitation que ce sont avant tout
les femmes et des hommes qui font notre
fierté cela même à qui on doit le
passage de l'hiver qui travaille dur sur
les chantiers de maintenance pour
produire l'électricité collègue qui nous
alimentent tous
une filière qui a été construite
une filière qui a été construite au
lendemain de la Seconde Guerre mondiale
sous la houlette de Marcel Paul et dont
le but était avant tout de promouvoir de
pouvoir fournir du courant et de
l'énergie au plus grand nombre le
nucléaire comme le service public de
l'électricité Ned ni de droite ni de
gauche c'est un savoir-faire français
mondialement reconnu portée depuis des
décennies par des générations d'ouvriers
de techniciens et d'ingénieur et que
tout député sincèrement attaché autre au
climat à notre souveraineté énergétique
et au pouvoir d'achat devrait défendre
au sein de cette Assemblée je vous
remercie
je vous remercie
la parole est à monsieur Guillaume casse
barian président de la commission des
affaires économiques
[Applaudissements]
s'il vous plaît mes chers collègues la
parole est uniquement à Monsieur
kasbarian merci pour votre attention
chers collègues merci merci madame la
présidente madame la ministre madame la
rapporteur mes chers collègues depuis
2017 notre majorité agit pour renouer
durablement avec la croissance le plein
emploi et la réindustrialisation du pays
pour atteindre ces objectifs économiques
la mère des batailles c'est celle de
l'énergie notre pays doit être capable
de produire plus d'électricité
décarbonée grâce au renouvelable et
grâce au nucléaire en même temps alors
que la loi d'accélération des énergies
renouvelables vient d'être promulguées
le 10 mars nous débutons aujourd'hui
l'examen du projet de loi permettant
d'accélérer la construction de nouvelles
installations nucléaires je souhaite à
cet égard saluer le formidable travail
de notre excellent rapporteur mode
Braison lors des auditions et pendant
les 17 heures où notre commission des
affaires économiques assiégée
le nucléaire repose sur un savoir-faire
français qui a fait dans les années 70
et 2000 70 à 2000 notre fierté toutefois
depuis les années 2000 la stratégie
énergétique de notre pays a connu
quelques-hermans bien illustrés par les
auditions menées par la commission
d'enquête en cours sur la perte de
souveraineté d'indépendance énergétique
de la France dont je salue les travaux
et le rapporteur de Normand et son
président Monsieur shellerger pour
éviter de reproduire les erreurs du
passé il faut que les travaux du nouveau
nucléaire annoncés par le Président de
la République dans le discours de
Belfort en février 2022 puisse se
dérouler dans un calendrier libéré
d'embûches administratives c'est
exactement l'objet de ce projet de loi
accélérer accélérer accélérer en faisant
gagner deux années dans le calendrier de
réalisation des trois premières paires
de pair chers collègues je sais que vous
avez du mal avec l'accélération vous
n'avez pas voté pour le projet de loi
sur l'énergie renouvelable vous allez
pas voter pour le projet sur nucléaire
on a compris que vous ne souhaitiez pas
accélérer pour le dire autrement chers
collègues en votant ce texte vous donnez
toutes les chances à notre pays de
réussir à mettre en service les
prochains réacteurs dès 2035 le retour
d'expérience de la construction de l'EPR
de flamand ville 3 Stéphane traverse en
parlera en parlera probablement a mis en
lumière plusieurs pistes d'amélioration
en premier lieu les difficultés
techniques ont établi la nécessité de
recruter et former dans des métiers
spécialisés à haute valeur ajoutée c'est
un chantier qui a déjà débuté comme la
illustré la première semaine des métiers
du nucléaire la semaine dernière en même
temps Flamanville a montré l'enjeu de
l'organisation logistique des travaux et
du bon déroulement de la maîtrise
d'oeuvre qui a engendré plusieurs
retards dans les premières années de ce
chantier sur des projets aussi colossaux
l'échéancement des travaux doit être
pensé avec précision
ce projet doit permettra dès la
délivrance de l'autorisation
environnementale dont la demande devrait
être déposée par EDF à la fin du premier
semestre de cette année pour Pandi 3 de
démarrer les travaux préparatoires
d'aménagement des terrasses c'est-à-dire
que c'est l'article 4 du texte ce
démarrage anticipé pourrait permettre
par rapport aux droits actuel de gagner
18 mois la construction des bâtiments de
l'îlot nucléaire pourrait commencer
après la délivrance de l'autorisation de
création d'une installation nucléaire
dont l'instruction prend entre 3 et 5
ans et dans la demande sera déposée en
même temps que celle de l'autorisation
environnementale le premier béton
nucléaire pourrait donc être coulé selon
les estimations au premier semestre 2027
pour les paires de réacteurs ultérieurs
l'article 2 permettrait un gain de temps
sur les procédures administratives de
l'ordre de six mois en accélérant la
procédure de mise en compatibilité des
documents d'urbanisme avec le projet
tout en garantissant l'association des
collectivités concernées il s'agit de
processus extrêmement lourd et complexe
qui implique des milliers de d'acteurs
et nous nous réjouissons que le texte
contrib à la fois à la simplification
administrative et à la sécurisation du
chemin critique des projets il en va
ainsi de la suppression de
l'autorisation d'urbanisme fusionnée
avec l'autorisation environnementale à
l'article 3 du texte ces mesures prises
dans leur ensemble c'est à dire en
angloie celle qui permet de mieux
sécuriser le parc existant je pense à
l'article 10 doivent nous permettre de
conforter pour l'avenir la sécurité de
notre approvisionnement électrique c'est
pourquoi je me réjouis de la large
majorité trouver en commission des
affaires économiques pour voter ce texte
moyennant les évolutions importantes que
nous avons adopté toujours dans le sens
de la simplicité et de l'efficacité des
procédures sur les 543 amendements
examinés en commission nous en avons
adopté un tiers 172 amendements de tous
les bancs dont 23% déposés par des
membres de l'opposition nous avons
conservé 5 des 8 articles ajoutés au
Sénat ce qui allaient dans le sens de la
simplification et de l'efficacité nous
en avez nous en avons ajouté 5 nouveaux
qui vont aussi dans ce sens j'espère que
nous saurons en séance publique
continuer à enrichir et améliorer le
texte en gardant à l'esprit nos
objectifs comme je l'ai déjà affirmé en
commission je ne doute pas qu'il existe
dans cette hémicycle une large majorité
de députés qui n'ont pas le nucléaire
honteux je vous remercie
je vous remercie nous en arrivons
maintenant à l'examen de la motion de
rejet préalable j'ai reçu de Monsieur
Boris Vallot et des membres du groupe
socialiste à parenté une motion de rejet
préalable déposée en application de
l'article 91 alinéa 5 du règlement la
parole est donc à Madame marine Noël
Baptiste
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le président de la commission
des affaires économiques madame la
rapporteur chers collègues jamais depuis
les chocs pétrolier de 1973 et de 79 les
enjeux énergétiques n'auront pris une
place si importante dans le débat public
et le quotidien de nos concitoyens des
enjeux de sobriété et de décarbonation
pour faire face au défi de la transition
écologique et de l'adaptation au
changement climatique un enjeu de
diversification pour gagner en
résilience et retrouver une souveraineté
alors que la guerre en Ukraine a
cruellement mis en lumière nos
dépendances un enjeu de régulation enfin
afin de relever tous ces défis en
protégeant nos biens communs que sont la
ressource en eau les sols et notre
biodiversité et en préservant le pouvoir
d'achat des Françaises et des Français
la compétitivité de nos entreprises et
les moyens de nos collectivités
territoriales
depuis 2019 un outil législatif est
prévu pour être le vecteur d'une vision
holistique de ces défis et des solutions
permettant de les relever il s'agit bien
évidemment de la loi de programmation
sur l'énergie et le climat que le
gouvernement doit déposer devant le
Parlement au plus tard le 1er juillet
2023 or madame la ministre le
gouvernement a fait le choix d'aborder
ses enjeux à l'envers selon nous et en
silo un plan de sobriété d'abord une loi
énergie renouvelable une loi nucléaire
et ensuite une loi de programmation
alors que l'électrification des usages
va faire augmenter notre consommation
électrique dans les 20 premières années
l'enjeu de la sobriété constitue le
premier pilier d'une stratégie
énergétique cohérente en loi de finance
pour 2023 notre groupe comme les autres
groupes de gauche à proposer des
investissements majeurs importants à la
hauteur des enjeux pour la rénovation
énergétique des bâtiments et de
développement de notre réseau
ferroviaire ils étaient financés dans la
taxation des super profits et l'abandon
de cerdant certains cadeaux fiscaux le
gouvernement n'a pas fait ce choix il a
fallu compter sur le sens des
responsabilités des Français pour
constater au moins cet hiver une moindre
consommation énergie
le second pilier celui de la
diversification vous avez présenté à
l'automne une loi pour accélérer la
production d'énergie renouvelable
promulguée vendredi dernier nous avions
lors des débats sur ce texte déjà dit
notre insatisfaction concernant cette
ordonne en ce moment législative
cependant il est vrai que la France est
déjà très en retard sur ses objectifs et
engagements internationaux en la matière
le seul pays de l'Europe l'Union
européenne dans cette situation
d'ailleurs de plus quel que soit le
scénario de si de mix énergétique retenu
parmi ceux proposés par RTE dans ses
futurs énergétiques 2050 la production
d'énergie solaire doit être multipliée
au moins par 7 celle éoliennes terrestre
au moins par deux et demi pour faire
face à des besoins d'environ 750 Téra
par an notre groupe a donc pris toute sa
part dans le renforcement de ce texte
que nous avons voté les choses sont
cependant tout à fait différentes
s'agissant de la production
électronucléaire sur les 6 scénaristes
de RTE 3 permettent d'atteindre la
neutralité carbone en 2050 sans nouveau
nucléaire les trois autres prévoient
outre la prolongation du parc historique
prévu dans ces 5 des 6 scénaris un mix
allant de 26% de nucléaires avec 8
nouveaux réacteurs à 50% de nucléaires
avec 14 nouveaux réacteurs et quelques
sms on comprend mieux la madame la
ministre madame la rapporteur le débat
que nous avons eu en commission et qui
nous amène en séance avec un texte qui
conserve une partie des dispositions de
programmation induite introduite par les
sénateurs LR parmi lesquels la question
du plafond de la part du nucléaire à 50%
dans notre mix énergétique et
l'évaluation des conséquences de la
construction de 14 réacteurs électro
nucléaire prévu à l'article 1er D
vous nous aviez dit en décembre
gouvernement comme rapporteur nous ne
voulons pas de disposition de
programmation dans la loi sur les
énergies renouvelables nous ne voulons
pas préempter la loi de programmation
énergies climat prévu à l'été dans
l'esprit qui nous a animé alors nous
avions retiré nos amendements ce sens en
commission vous nous avez dit cette
fois-ci l'inverse ou plus exactement
vous nous avez dit que vous assumiez le
projet d'un nouveau programme
électronucléaire est donc il vous
semblait logique que le texte reflète
cela mais madame la rapporteur madame la
ministre ne pensez-vous pas que nous
aussi nous aurions souhaité que le texte
sur les énergies renouvelables se
reflètent notre vision potentiellement
différentes de la vôtre une vision dont
l'objectif et d'atteindre un mix
énergétique diversifié composé à 100%
d'énergie renouvelable dès que possible
une vision qui se veut cependant
pragmatique scientifiquement éclairé et
consciente des contraintes industrielles
et humaines à cet égard face au retard
pris dans le développement de ces
énergie est dans l'effort de sobriété le
scénario dans lequel nous aurions besoin
d'un nucléaire de transition composé de
la prolongation d'un parc existant
jusqu'à à 50 voire 60 ans et d'un nombre
a définir de nouveaux réacteurs
électronucléaires devient de plus en
plus certains mais bien entendu une
telle décision ne peut se prendre
qu'avec une vision globale tenant compte
de l'ensemble des énergies et bien sûr
dans le véhicule législatif et la loi de
programmation elle ne peut se prendre
qu'en tenant compte des interrogations
légitimes que nous avons exprimées en
commission sur notre capacité ou plus
précisément celle de EDF amené à bien et
de manière concomitante la conception et
la construction de nouveaux réacteurs le
grand carénage pour prolonger le parc
existant et une campagne de réparation
de défauts majeurs de corrosion sous
contrainte et de fatigue thermique dans
les ramifications semblent s'étendre
chaque semaine au-delà des contraintes
industrielles disposons-nous des moyens
humains suffisants en particulier pour
les ouvriers spécialisés bien peu a été
fait à ce jour pour répondre aux enjeux
d'enseignement et de formation ne
serait-ce que pour faire face aux
besoins du parc actuel
quel est donc votre stratégie de gestion
du combestible et des déchets à l'amant
à Laval et sans dépendance vis-à-vis des
tas comme la Russie conservez-nous comme
objectif l'enfouissement définitif en
coups géologique profonde de déchets
ultime vous défendez un nouveau
programme électronucléaire avant que
nous ayez nous ayons pu débattre au
Parlement de tous ces enjeux nous avons
proposé des amendements pour une réelle
programmation stratégique sur le
combustible et les déchets mais aussi
sur les moyens humains pas seulement sur
le nucléaire mais pour l'ensemble de
notre stratégie énergie climat vous avez
préféré les amendements et l'air et de
votre majorité qui ne regardent le
problème qu'en silo sous le seul prisme
nucléaire car vous oubliez qu'avec votre
futur loi sur l'industrie verte le
développement des énergies renouvelables
et les besoins du secteur nucléaire les
tensions sur les métiers les compétences
sur les matières premières seront
énormes et ses ambitions seront
concurrence
votre revirement sur ce sujet de la
planification nous interroge sur le
devenir même de cette loi de
programmation sur l'énergie et le climat
des bruits de plus en plus insistants se
font jour 41 report inédit de son examen
et les modifications apportées en
commission vous permettent de mener à
bien votre vision sur le nucléaire sans
avoir besoin de celle-ci j'espère madame
la ministre que ce ne sont que des
bruits sans l'admettre en tant que tel
cette loi d'accélération du nucléaire
est calibrée pour le Seigneur le
scénario n03 de RTE avec 50% nucléaires
et 14 nouveaux EPR et SMR et 50%
d'énergie renouvelable prenez vous
l'engagement madame la ministre au nom
du gouvernement et devant la
représentation nationale que ce texte
sera bien déposé avant le 1er juillet
2023 et examiné avant la fin de cette
année
la confiance n'excluant pas le contrôle
nous défendrons un amendement visant à
conditionner l'entrée en vigueur de la
loi dont nous débattons aujourd'hui à la
promulgation de la loi de programmation
énergie climat
au-delà des enjeux de programmation
plusieurs autres dispositions de ce
texte ne nous semblent nous nous semble
poser des difficultés majeures vous avez
réécrit l'article 5
afin d'aller jusqu'à dispenser
totalement les installations nucléaires
d'application de la loi littorale sans
même intégrer un minimum d'objectifs de
limitation de l'artificialisation des
sols de préservation des écosystèmes et
de compensation comme nous ne vous
l'avons proposé pour l'énergie solaire
nous avons su prendre le temps avec
notre collègue bottorel pour équilibrer
la préservation des terres agricoles et
les enjeux de production d'énergie
renouvelables sur le nucléaire vous
préférez la stratégie du bulldozer et
nous le regrettons
je pourrais développer d'autres exemples
comme l'article 13 mais je souhaite
m'arrêter sur des dispositions qui ne
figuraient pas dans le texte initial ni
dans celui examiné par le Sénat
d'ailleurs il s'agit bien évidemment de
la décision présidentielle de refonder
l'organisation de la sûreté nucléaire
dans notre pays avec la fusion
absorption de l'IRSN par la SN
disons-le d'emblée madame la ministre
annoncé en comité secret une
réorganisation de la Sûreté Nucléaire
quoi qu'on puisse penser du projet sur
le fond au moment où l'opérateur doit
faire valider la prolongation de
l'exploitant du parc existant de
l'exploitation du parc existant excusez
moi et potentiellement un nouveau
programme n'est pas de nature à donner
confiance aux Français dans laquelle
idée de l'indépendance de ce contrôle le
vert sans concertation par amendement en
cours de navette sans aucune étude
d'impact sans avis du Conseil d'État et
par ailleurs un affront au Parlement qui
a été dénoncé même au sein de votre
majorité on ne parle pas ici d'un
amendement sur un taux de TVA réduits
sur les courses hippiques nous sommes
sur un sujet sensible aux conséquences
majeures en cas de défaillance sur le
fond nous ne disons pas qu'aucune hameau
amélioration de l'organisation de la
sûreté nucléaire n'est possible cela
mérite bien sûr débat mais quand vous
justifiez cette réforme par un constat
qui est à l'opposé de celui dressé par
la Cour des comptes dans son rapport de
2021 sur la gestion et le fonctionnement
de l'URSS cela nous laisse dubitatif en
tout état de cause il est impératif de
maintenir une organisation assurante la
séparation des missions d'expertise et
de décision
indispensables à l'indépendance de la
première seule la science doit fonder
l'expertise il appartient ensuite au
régulateur d'équilibrer ses
prescriptions avec les contraintes
économiques industrielles et budgétaires
lorsqu'il rend ses décisions
dual de l'ASN et de l'URSS apportent
cette assurance comme c'est le cas
d'ailleurs dans le domaine de la santé
avec lances et l'inrae qui ont signé le
3 mars dernier une nouvelle convention
quinquennale de collaboration vous qui
souhaitez plus de synergie entre la SN
et l'IRSN la preuve que cela est
possible sans fusion il est également et
social pour la bonne information du
public que les avis de l'expertise
demeur public indépendamment de ce
relatif à la décision afin que tous les
éléments d'arbitrage soient connus
si vous avez heureusement abandonné le
transfert de la recherche au CEA ce qui
aurait lourdement affaibli l'expertise à
terme elle demeurera la variable
d'ajustement budgétaire d'une entité
chargée dans le volume d'émission de
contrôle va exploser enfin vous n'avez
apporté aucune information quant aux
devenir des activités économiques de
l'IRSN par exemple dans le domaine de la
dosimétrie
supprimons donc ces articles 11 bis et
11 TER ayant un débat public sera une
concertation véritable sur le sujet
majeur et revenez avec un dispositif
dans le cadre de la loi de programmation
énergie et climat initial vous l'avez
vous même dit Madame la Ministre pendant
les débats en commission ce projet ne
sera mis en oeuvre que au bout de 15 à
18 mois de concertation donc quel est
l'intérêt d'agir aujourd'hui dans la
précipitation
ne pas le faire c'est à dire ne pas nous
permettre d'avoir un débat serein et
sérieux sur cette se rapprochement c'est
renforcer l'idée selon laquelle ce texte
de programmation ne verra jamais le jour
ainsi madame la ministre madame la
rapporteur se préjugue loin tel
qu'adopter en commission préhe le débat
sur la loi de programmation énergie et
climat et actes un scénario de relance
du nucléaire à hauteur de 50% du mix
énergétique futur sans débat d'ensemble
il remet en cause sans fondement
apparent l'organisation de la Sûreté
Nucléaire encore tournant les
obligations constitutionnelles qui
auraient permis d'éclairer le Parlement
sur les conséquences de cette réforme et
enfin il n'assure pas la
proportionnalité entre les enjeux
énergétiques et ceux de préservation de
l'environnement à valeur
constitutionnelle au regard des
atteintes de la loi littérale à la loi
littoral et à l'insuffisance prise en
compte des enjeux du changement
climatique et notamment de la
disponibilité de la ressource en eau il
y a donc lieu dans l'attente de la
présentation de la loi de programmation
pour l'énergie et le climat et puisque
nous n'avons plus l'outil de la motion
de renvoi en commission d'opposer la
motion de rejet au présent projet de loi
de programmation de 14 réacteurs
électronucléaires et de la
réorganisation de la Sûreté Nucléaire je
vous remercie
je vous remercie avant de passer la
parole à Madame à la mini je vous
indique que sur le vote de la motion de
rejet préalable je suis saisie par le
groupe renaissance d'une demande de
scrutin public qui est annoncée dans
l'enceinte de l'Assemblée nationale
et donc nous en arrivons madame la
ministre vous avez la parole
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
Baptiste je dois taper à ordire toute ma
surprise lorsque j'ai été informée de
cette motion de rejet sur un texte
concernant le nucléaire de la part du
groupe socialiste d'autant que je
connais la considération que vous portez
à notre mix électrique décarbonées et
aux bras armés de notre politique
énergétique EDF
vous soulevez dans votre potion de
censure la question du périmètre de ce
texte et de fait que ce texte doit être
examiné pour ce qu'il est c'est-à-dire
un texte d'accélération des procédures
administratives d'installation nucléaire
madame la députée baptistel je suis
entièrement d'accord avec vous le
gouvernement la rapporteur la majorité
partage votre ligne je nécessite de le
dire au Sénat où je rappelle que des
objectifs programmatifs ont été
introduits en commission ou le
gouvernement n'est pas représenté ce
texte n'est pas un texte de
programmation énergétique ce n'est pas
la loi de programmation énergie climat
avant l'heure c'est la position que j'ai
défendu au Sénat c'est celle que j'ai
défendu en commission pas plus tard que
la semaine dernière et c'est celle que
je continuerai de défendre lors de
l'examen en hémicycle c'est d'ailleurs
cette position qui a conduit le
gouvernement madame l'a rapporteur la
majorité plusieurs groupes de
l'opposition apporter des amendements de
suppression des éléments programmatiques
il y a eu un consensus fort sur ce point
en commission me semble-t-il le symbole
est en sans doute l'ancien article
premier B qui introduisait un plancher
de 50% du nucléaire dans notre mix
électrique nous avons donc pris nos
responsabilités en le supprimant vous
soulevez la réintroduction du plafond de
50% supprimé par le Sénat mais
précisément cela revient à réintroduire
un objectif programmatique et après en
tel la future loi de programmation
énergétique et la position du
gouvernement est parfaitement claire sur
ce sujet ni plancher ni plafond car
qu'est-ce que nous devons faire
aujourd'hui c'est envoyer un signal à
notre filière qui a longtemps souffert
d'injonctions contradictoires et je ne
me permettrai pas de revenir sur les
travaux de la commission d'enquête sur
la souveraineté énergétique présidée par
le député Raphaël schenender et dont
Antoine Armand il rapporteur mais il met
en exergue combien certaines décisions
passées ont pu s'apparenter à des coups
d'arrêt donc neuropliquons pas ne
reproduisons pas ce qui ont été des
erreurs du passé qui je pense sont
reconnus par tout sur tous les bancs
s'agissant de la fusion entre l'URSS et
la SN là aussi je le redis il s'agit ni
plus ni moins de mettre deux entités
publiques qui interviennent sur la même
mission de service public sous la même
bannière publique qui se trouve être la
plus protectrice en termes
d'indépendance vis-à-vis du gouvernement
qu'aurait-on entendu si nous avions
apporté la SN à l'IRSN correct si nous
avions demandé à la SN de ne plus être
une autorité administrative indépendante
et contrairement à ce que vous insinuez
ce texte ne touche pas une seule virgule
de nos procédures de sûreté nucléaire et
oui mais il faut dire la vérité aux
Français il le touche pas une seule
virgule à nos procédures de sûreté
nucléaire c'est même procédures et cette
autorité qui sont reconnues
internationalement et qui sont
aujourd'hui au travail pardon madame la
députée si vous aviez l'amabilité de me
laisser parler j'essaye de vous écouter
et je réponds à vos questions
donc je le redis notre objectif est
clairement de défendre cette excellence
de notre sûreté nucléaire qui amène
aujourd'hui la HASN à prendre des
positions très fermes vis-à-vis d'EDF et
je veux quand même répondre sur le sujet
là aussi où il y a un petit peu des
insinuations sur les sur les fissures
découvrir des fissures de fatigue
thermique sur une tuyauterie c'est un
peu aussi banal que de découvrir que des
équipements vieillissent et je rappelle
que ces pièces sont remplacées donc
attention effectivement ne pas laisser
le discrédit sur une filière
d'excellence sur 220 000 collaborateurs
qui travaillent jour et nuit pour
assurer notre résilience énergétique
c'est inconvenant et inapproprié après
l'hiver que nous avons passé
[Applaudissements]
enfin contrairement à ce que vous
indiquez si le texte
ou sécuriser le statut des
oly RSN mais demain nous allons
travailler jusqu'à sur l'organisation de
cette réforme pour trouver justement les
meilleurs voix et moyen d'organisation
pour répondre à notre objectif de sûreté
nucléaire et d'indépendance nucléaire je
vais maintenant revenir sur le troisième
volet de votre propos qui sont sur les
procédures sur les procédures vous vous
étonnez qu'il n'y a pas une exacte
j'irai linéarité ou cohérence avec le
texte que nous avons voté sur les
énergies renouvelables mais il y a une
bonne raison à cela c'est qu'aujourd'hui
les raccordements existent sur les
institutions nucléaires aujourd'hui ces
raccordements sont faits et ce que nous
faisons sur le nucléaire a beaucoup
moins d'impact que des raccordements
multiples et c'est normal c'est le la
loi du genre des énergies renouvelables
d'être des installations atomisées sur
le territoire
vous donne pas encore avoir les
raccordements donc en fait nous avons le
même objectif celui d'accélérer les
énergies renouvelables celui de relancer
le nucléaire pour être au service de nos
objectifs climatiques et je pense être
du côté de la cohérence politique en
matière de lutte contre le changement
climatique et pour ces raisons j'invite
à voter contre votre motion de censure
de rejet je vous remercie donc nous en
arrivons maintenant aux explications de
vote et tous ceux qui ont demandé la
parole vont pouvoir s'exprimer et donc
le premier monsieur Gérard le seul vous
avez la parole pour les explications de
vote
oui effectivement monsieur le seul on ne
s'entend pas même moi vous ne m'entendez
pas parler donc je demanderai à chaque
collègue de bien vouloir écouter
monsieur le seul qui a la parole merci
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre madame monsieur les rapporteurs
chers collègues
l'accélération que vous nous proposez ne
doit pas conduire à la précipitation
madame la ministre ce projet de loi se
focalise en effet sur la construction
des EPR sans poser la question plus
large de la filière nucléaire qui
s'étend de l'approvisionnement avec
l'uranium en passant par la production
d'énergie et la gestion des risques
qu'il l'entourent jusqu'à la gestion des
déchets dont les plus dangereux sont
radioactifs pour des millions d'années
cantonnez le sujet du nucléaire à
l'accélération des procédures de
construction des EPERS et non seulement
totalement lacunaire mais laisse
également penser que le débat sur le
sujet est clos et que la question du mix
énergétique français serait déjà tranché
avant même l'arrivée de la loi de
programmation plus rénale de l'énergie
de plus
madame la ministre
le projet de fusion IRSN ASN par la voie
précipitée des amendements en commission
est venu totalement polluer le débat et
la sereine réflexion qui aurait dû
présider à nos débats donc sans
insinuation pas d'études d'impact sur
cette fusion sans doute d'ailleurs
envisagé dans les bureaux de l'Élysée
pas David du Conseil d'État pas de
présentation argumentée que nous vous
avions demandé sur les avantages et les
inconvénients de cette fusion pas de
prise en compte des organisations
syndicales et de la vie des travailleurs
du nucléaire que nous saluons pour leur
sérieux ici dans cette hémicycle pas
d'avis pas de prise en compte de
l'ensemble des autorités et des entités
publiques que vous avez évoqué pour
toutes ces raisons nous vous appelons
chers collègues à voter pour cette
notion de rejet de ce texte non pas
d'accélération madame la ministre mais
de ce texte de précipitation
je vous remercie la parole est
maintenant à Madame Julie la ernus
nous contestons fortement l'opportunité
de ce projet de loi tant il dépasse
largement l'objet initial pour lequel il
avait été présenté en effet madame la
ministre en maintenant la suppression de
nos objectifs de réduction de la part du
nucléaire et en inscrivant votre volonté
de construire 14 EPR vous voulez du pied
vos engagements de respecter le débat
sur la programmation énergétique à venir
et surtout vous piétinez les conclusions
des débats publics qui viennent de
s'achever cela nous paraît profondément
antidémocratique vous nous mettez comme
nos concitoyens devant le fait accompli
c'est inacceptable vous nous demandez
aujourd'hui de débattre d'un texte
attend de force une relance une
nucléaire alors que la filière va
extrêmement mal les piscines de déchets
débordent les opérateurs du nucléaire
sont fragilisés par des déboires
industriels en cascade en France comme à
l'étranger nos centrales vieillissent
mal pour preuve la moitié du parc était
à l'arrêt cet été et de nouvelles
fissures ont été retrouvées sur deux
réacteurs d'une ampleur inégalée on mise
tout sur un pari technologique plus que
risqué et comme si cela ne suffisait pas
on ne sait même pas comment le financer
EDF est endetté à 65 milliards plus que
France Télécom avant de s'adresser ses
effectifs aux deux tiers sans parler de
la robustesse des centrales face au
changement climatique cela ressemble
plus à un mantra auquel vous vous
accrochez quoi qu'il en coûte c'est
totalement irresponsable ce passage en
force s'illustre aussi dans votre
volonté de profiter de cette loi pour
démanteler de force l'URSS avec l'aide
de l'extrême droite le même
rassemblement national qui propose de
démanteler les éoliennes et construire
plus de 20 nouveaux réacteurs de notre
pays d'ici 13 ans alors que des dires
d'absolument tout le monde industriel
scientifique c'est simplement impossible
et cela sans réflexion sur les
conséquences d'une très belle
fragilisation de notre modèle robuste de
sûreté
une fuite en avant extrêmement grave
irresponsable et dangereuse pour toutes
ces raisons les écologistes ont avec
force cette motion de projet et invite
tous celles et ceux qui le soient pour
ou contenu nucléaire
la parole est maintenant à Monsieur
Sébastien Jumel
madame la ministre chers
il y a dans les propos développés par
notre collègue socialiste baptistal des
propos justes des propos légitimes des
propos que nous partageons notamment sur
le fait que vous vous y preniez à
l'envers
nous aurions souhaité nous l'avons dit à
plusieurs reprises un débat démocratique
sur
l'épaisseur du mixte l'étendue du mixte
sur les enjeux stratégiques de politique
énergétique intégrant sobriété économie
d'énergie et structuration des filières
et ce débat démocratique aurait dû
précéder des lois techniques visant à
atteindre ses objectifs c'est
l'appréciation que les élus sur les
bancs de gauche portent d'ailleurs la
justesse de ces arguments aurait dû
conduire nos collègues socialistes à ne
pas voter la loi sur les EnR je le dis
entre parenthèses puisqu'elle venait
précéder le débat démocratique sur le
plan qui réanuel de l'énergie en
cohérence ce qui fait la richesse de la
gauche je veux le dire tranquillement
c'est que sur ce sujet là elle est
diverse
et cette diversité vous le savez va
s'exprimer dans les débats qui s'ouvrent
et nous le ferons tranquillement ce qui
fait la cohérence de la gauche c'est sa
réaffirmation à l'attachement de
plusieurs principes d'abord l'énergie
doit échapper à la logique de marché de
ce point de vue de nombreux
gouvernements ont abîmé la maîtrise
publique de l'énergie et je leur en veux
la cohérence de la gauche c'est de
veiller à un niveau de sûreté de
sécurité qui ne doit pas faire débat et
de ce point de vue le fait que la fusion
de l'irsm ASN tombe comme un cheveu sur
la soupe nous préoccupe et réouvre
d'ailleurs une boîte de Pandore pour
ceux qui ont des arguments visant à
s'opposer à la filière nucléaire tout
cela nous conduit donc à souhaiter que
le débat apporte des éclaircissements et
tout ça milite pour que le groupe
communiste dans sa majorité en tout cas
s'abstiennent sur la motion de rejet
présentée
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre mesdames les rapporteurs mes
chers collègues le groupe liotte aura
l'occasion d'exprimer un certain nombre
de convergences avec ce qu'a évoqué la
collègue baptistel notamment et le
collègue jumelles vient de le faire sur
la question du calendrier de la méthode
et des choix parfois surprenants pour ne
pas dire hasardeux qui ont été faits
nous aurons l'occasion je le crois de
débattre et peut-être sereinement de
combattre pied à pied les propositions
que vous avez déposées par voie
d'amendement notamment sur la fusion
IRSN ASN sans jamais répondre à des
questions basiques de pourquoi
maintenant pourquoi comme ça qu'est-ce
qui finalement crée les difficultés qui
vous amènent à cette décision néanmoins
le groupe liberté indépendant outre-mer
et territoires considèrent que le texte
initial présenté pour l'objectif
d'accélération du nucléaire des éléments
intéressants que nous souhaitons pouvoir
porter au débat dans ces conditions nous
souhaitons que ce débat et lieu dans la
diversité et dans j'allais dire la
construction d'un objectif partagé sans
revenir sur la l'absence de la
programmation puisque nous aurons sans
doute l'occasion de le faire à travers
les DG et les débats nous ne
participerons pas à ce vote sur la
motion de rejet même si nous partageons
un certain nombre d'objectifs qui sont
relevés par la collecte je vous remercie
je vous remercie la parole est
maintenant Monsieur Antoine normand
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre mes chers collègues
devant cette volonté du Parti socialiste
de rejeter en bloc sans débat un texte
parce que le Sénat aurait supprimé
l'objectif de 50 % du nucléaire on peut
s'interroger c'est peut-être la
nostalgie du quinquennat de François
Hollande en matière d'énergie nucléaire
mais rassurez-vous rassurez-vous mes
chers collègues même vos anciens
camarades sont prêts à tourner la page
il se trouve qu'entre en tant que
rapporteur de la commission d'enquête
sur la souveraineté énergétique j'ai eu
l'honneur d'interroger vos dirigeants
vos anciens dirigeants socialistes sur
la loi 2015 vous savez c'est la loi qui
a consacré la réduction du nucléaire à
50%. c'était un accord de coin de table
qui allait affaiblir durablement la
filière selon Arnaud Montebourg ancien
ministre socialiste il n'y a eu aucune
étude préalable sérieuse pour citer
l'ancien Premier ministre socialiste
Manuel Valls c'était un objectif que je
ne souhaitais pas voir figuré dans la
loi enfin selon l'ancienne ministre
socialiste Ségolène Royal qui a présenté
cette loi devant notre assemblée
c'est peut-être plus sûrement d'ailleurs
la peur de froisser publiquement vos
alliés au lv et LFI qui en commission
des affaires économiques se sont à
nouveau illustrés par leur opposition
systématique aveugle à l'énergie
nucléaire au mépris de l'urgence
climatique au mépris de l'urgence
énergétique quand la production mes
chers collègues de les d'électricité
nucléaire émet 70 fois moins de CO2 que
le charbon 40 fois moins que le gaz 4
fois moins que le solaire deux fois
moins que l'hydraulique et autant que
l'éolien difficile en tout cas donc de
suivre les méandres sinueux de la pensée
socialiste qui s'est abstenu en
commission et qui vient ici déposer une
motion de rejet préalable cette solution
avec le groupe Renaissance nous la
repousserons cette motion Elle vous
place une nouvelle fois je le regrette
dans le camp de l'obstruction et de
l'irresponsabilité
je vous remercie la parole est
maintenant à Monsieur Nicolas dragon
merci madame la présidente
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
troisième industrie française avec
220000 emplois derrière l'aviation et
l'automobile le nucléaire a contribué à
l'indépendance nationale de notre pays
sur le plan de l'énergie pendant des
décennies nos compatriotes nos
entreprises notre industrie ont pu
profiter de l'électricité la moins chère
d'Europe et la plus abondante si
abondante que nous en revendions à nos
voisins y compris à ceux d'outre-reins
qui pleuvent qu'il neige qu'il vente
l'approvisionnement électrique était
assurée les gains de compétitivité de
nos entreprises pouvaient s'en ressentir
nos habitants eux se souviennent de leur
facture peu élevée avec regret
rappelons-nous si les risques de coupure
électrique de cet hiver révélant aux
yeux de tous le pita le piteux état du
secteur énergétique français un piteux
état résultat de politique
ultralibérale et européenne qui ont
cassé le service public de l'énergie et
déstabiliser nos entreprises comme PDF
la responsabilité de ceux sur ces
banques qui ont gouverné qui gouvernent
encore et lourdes ce projet de loi dont
nous débattons aujourd'hui va dans le
bon sens mais nous nous pouvons que
déplorer le temps perdu du fait même de
la majorité qui le porte et qui
proposait sous la précédente législature
de réduire la part du nucléaire à 50 %
du mix énergétique cette situation
déplorable est aussi le triste bilan de
ceux qui n'ont cessé de dénigrer le
nucléaire avec une constance pour ne pas
dire un aveuglement mes chers collègues
écologistes en portant cette notion de
rejet vous êtes finalement en accord
avec votre ligne depuis des décennies
toujours aussi bornés à combattre une
énergie pourtant décarbonée toujours
aussi pro à défendre vos saints
éoliennes qui défigurent nos paysages ne
compensant en rien la production
d'énergie via le nucléaire
face à un tel sectarisme le groupe
rassemblement national ne votera
évidemment pas cette motion de rejet
bien au contraire ces élus s'attacheront
à défendre la relance de notre filière
nucléaire je vous remercie je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur
Christophe Bex
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre mesdames les rapporteurs chers
collègues le 6 mars 74 Pierre Messmer
Premier ministre trois semaines avant le
décès du président Pompidou annonce sans
aucune discussion ni débat que le pays
fait le choix de la tombe en plein choc
pétrolier l'indépendance énergétique et
l'argument massue on peut comprendre
l'opinion pro-nucléaire mais 50 ans
après il est temps de sortir de la magie
de l'atome
sécurité il y a eu catastrophe en 79 aux
États-Unis en 86 à Tchernobyl en 2011 à
Fukushima indépendance de façade des 75
avec la licence Westinghouse le made in
America fait la gloire du nucléaire
français pour le retraitement de
l'uranium l'industrie nucléaire
française est prise aux pièces de sa
dépendance avec la Russie
dépendance totale au niveau de la
ressource fossile l’uranium importé
provient principalement du Niger et du
Kazakhstan
le nucléaire n'est pas bon pour le
climat les milliards investis seront au
détriment des renouvelables
le climat n'est pas bon pour le
nucléaire le manque d'eau remet en cause
le fonctionnement des centrales la
multiplication des événements extrêmes
accentue le risque qui d'inondation des
réacteurs
l'industrie atomique est un avion certes
avec des ailes mais c'est en train
d'atterrissage bure ne doit pas être la
déchetterie du nucléaire je vous invite
à imaginer un chantier en cours en 2023
qui aurait commencé en 1871 ce n'est pas
sérieux il n'y a pas de justification
économique et climatique a lancé
industriellement une filière euper en
France
l'énergie nucléaire ne fournit que 2,5%
de la demande d'énergie finalement
mondiale et c'est inscrite contre la
volonté de toutes le présent c'est le
soleil levant l'océan c'est aussi le
changement de nos modes de vie de
consommation alors la parole est à
Monsieur Olivier Marlet
la présidente nos collègues du groupe
socialiste ont décidément étonnants il y
a quelques jours à peine il nous propose
avec
un Roland de patriotisme économique on
n'avait pas connu depuis longtemps un
texte de nationalisation de DF on se dit
EDF je vous rappelle première
fournisseur d'électricité producteur
d'électricité au monde champion champion
du nucléaire alors on se dit formidable
formidable les communistes qui eux ont
toujours été fidèles au consensus
national sur le nucléaire ont dû les
ramener un petit peu dans le droit
chemin et puis patatra quelques jours
après on vous entend replonger dans le
nuclearo scepticisme sans doute
avez-vous là écoutez un peu plus vos
collègues vos collègues des vers qui
vous ont applaudis avec avec frénésie et
vous nous ressortez vos vieilles
baderbes
50% de production nucléaire maximum
comme vous avez été écrit par Moïse sur
les tables de la loi alors qu'on sait
tous désormais que ça a été griffonné
sur un coin de table par François
Hollande donc tout ça n'est pas n'est
pas digne de vous mes chers collègues
surtout vous chers marina et batistel
que l'on sait si compétentes sur les
questions d'énergie si compétente et qui
avait mené un combat si intéressant pour
défendre
l'énergie hydroélectrique dans notre
pays on s'en voudrait de ne pas vous
entendre dans ce débat sur la relance du
nucléaire et donc pour vous permettre de
vous exprimer de prendre toute la place
que vous devez prendre dans ce débat
nous voterons contre cette notion de
renvoi de rejet pardon préalable merci
je vous remercie d'avoir les maintenant
à Madame Louise Morel
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre monsieur le président de
commission madame la rapporteur chers
collègues si elle ne nous surprend plus
cette motion de rejet déposée par nos
collègues de la nupesse est une fois de
plus l'expression d'un déni de vérité
cette démarche est le reflet d'une
position dogmatique sur le sujet du
nucléaire où chacune des priorités
environnementales devraient s'opposer au
lieu de se hiérarchiser or être
écologiste ces rechercher toutes les
solutions possibles pour préserver notre
planète du changement climatique et de
ses effets et l'urgence actuelle ne nous
permet pas en responsabilité de nous
faire l'économie d'une électricité
décarbonée telle que le nucléaire ce
déni de vérité n'est pas nouveau
rappelons-nous des louis-anges de
Dominique voanet il est un peu plus de
20 ans sur le sujet en appelant sur le
sujet du gaz le doublement de la
consommation de gaz naturel au niveau
mondial elle affirmait et je la cite
l'Europe a tout intérêt à diversifier
son approvisionnement et à jouer un rôle
actif dans la construction des grands
gazoducs internationaux rappelons-nous
également de ces louanges sur le charbon
expliquant que celui-ci n'est pas
condamné par la menace du changement
climatique vous l'aurez compris ces
propos sont en décalage complet avec
l'exigence de trouver des solutions
concrètes et à la hauteur du changement
climatique soyons cette fois-ci à la
hauteur pour cela chers collègues être
démocrate c'est laisser au parlementaire
que nous sommes la possibilité de
débattre de ce sujet si indispensable
pour l'avenir énergétique de notre pays
un débat qui je le rappelle est attendu
par les Français laissons donc l'examen
de ce texte avoir lieu et rejetons en
masse cette motion je vous remercie
je vous remercie nous allons maintenant
procéder au scrutin j'ai donc mettre au
voile la motion de rejet préalable je
vous prie de regagner vos places
le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
alors le résultat du scrutin votant 189
exprimé 184 majorités 93 pour 60 contre
124 l'Assemblée nationale n'a pas adopté
la motion de rejet est donc pas adoptée
et nous entamons donc la discussion
générale et Madame Anna pig vous avez la
parole
[Applaudissements]
merci de quitter les mystiques dans le
silence chers collègues merci beaucoup
madame la présidente madame la ministre
madame la rapporteur monsieur le
président de commission
chers collègues
en décembre dernier nous avons ici même
le projet de Loire relatif à
l'accélération de la production
d'énergie renouvelable
quelques semaines plus tard nous
débutons ce jour l'examen en séance
publique du projet de loi visant à
relancer notre filière nucléaire quel
point commun entre ces deux textes d'une
part un allègement parfois hasardeuse
des procédures administratives en
vigueur pour faciliter les installations
d'énergie renouvelables et nucléaire
d'autre part une fâcheuse tendance à
préempter le débat sur les grandes
orientations énergétiques du pays alors
que la loi de programmation sur
l'énergie et le climat doit être examiné
dans quelques mois
curieuse façon de concevoir la fabrique
de la loi que de vous assurer avant même
que la stratégie générale de politique
énergétique soit établie que rien ne
viendra perturber votre dessin
d'une
nous ne partageons pas cette conception
les laboration de la loi mais cette
dernière est sans doute fidèle à la
volonté du Président de la République
en effet n'a-t-il pas décidé seul il y a
à peine plus d'un an maintenant de
relancer notre industrie nucléaire mais
venons en concrètement au projet de loi
qui nous intéresse aujourd'hui dans un
contexte mondial où les besoins
d'électricité sont croissants nous
disposons dorénavons de moins de 30 ans
pour atteindre l'objectif de neutralité
carbone que nous nous sommes fixés à cet
égard le groupe socialiste et apparenté
n'est pas principalement anti-nucléaire
nous assumons même la nécessité de cette
énergie décarbonée et pilotable une
énergie de transition à même d’éviter
que les dérèglement climatiques ne
soient irréversible pour autant nous ne
pouvons pas raisonnablement approuver la
relance que vous proposez et ce pour
plusieurs raisons premièrement parce que
votre projet va irrémédiablement se
heurter à la complexité du réel la
France n'a pas mené de programme de
construction de plusieurs réacteurs
quasi simultanément depuis de plus de 20
ans ce constat est synonyme d'un
véritable manque de compétences
industriels nos flamants ville 3 et
certainement le meilleur exemple d'une
dégradation notable de l'outil de
production et enfin d'un délitement du
tissu des sous-traitants dont nous
payons collectivement le prix
aujourd'hui tout cela l'Autorité de
Sûreté Nucléaire on a parfaitement
conscience raison pour laquelle elle
appelle un appelant Marshall qui
pourrait s'avérer être une chimère
l'exploitant EDF ne dit pas autre chose
la pyramide des âges entraînera le
départ à la retraite de 70 000 des 220
000 travailleurs de la filière dans les
années à venir dans le même temps la
relance souhaitée nécessitera environ
300 000 personnes pour la rendre
effective il va donc falloir trouver et
former 150 000 ingénieurs techniciens
ouvriers au cours des 10 prochaines
années dans des secteurs parfois en très
fortes tensions deuxièmement parce que
la relance que vous appelez de vos vœux
ne tient absolument pas compte du cycle
de vie du combustible lequel constitue
pourtant d'ores et déjà un enjeu majeur
nous proposerons au cours de son examen
la création d'une loi de programmation
entièrement dédié au cycle de vie du
combustible ainsi que la remise d'un
rapport déterminant les moyens à mettre
en oeuvre pour garantir la réussite de
chaque étape de l'extraction au stockage
définitif en passant par le recyclage le
retraitement enfin votre volonté de
fusion absorption de LyX et RSN par
l'ASN est à la fois grave et préoccupant
sur la forme d'abord une réorganisation
de cette ampleur ne peut se faire par
voie d'amendement sans aucune étude
d'impact à rebours des conclusions de la
Cour des comptes sur le fond ensuite ce
que vous estimez être une fluidification
étant parfaite contradiction avec l'idée
de maintenir une indépendance entre la
fonction de régulateur de la SN et celle
d'expertise de l'IRSN qui fait pourtant
aujourd'hui la force de notre modèle de
sûreté en tout état de cause le signal
envoyé à l'orée d'une prolongation du
parc existant et du nevevent paraît
aventureux en matière de sûreté
nucléaire la France est considérée à
juste titre comme une référence à
travers le monde
et notre organisation y participent
grandement nous veillerons avec force à
ce qu'il en reste ainsi car nous voulons
pas d'un nucléaire low cost
la relance souhaitée par le Président de
la République aussi discutable soit-elle
et nous en discuterons lors de la loi de
programmation ne doivent en aucun cas
être un prétexte à un événement par le
bas de nos normes de sécurité
derrière ce projet de loi comme pour
celui relatif aux énergies renouvelables
déjà évoquées se pose une question bien
plus vaste celle des orientations
énergétiques et les représentations
nationales souhaitent donner à la France
pour les prochaines années
à l'heure où les factures énergétiques
des Français s'envolent nous veillerons
légitimement tout au long de l'examen de
ce texte à ce que leurs intérêts soient
préservés dès lors nous adopterons notre
position sur ce texte à l'évolution des
débats et au sort qui sera réservé à nos
propositions d'amendements au cours des
prochains jours je vous remercie je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur Xavier
Albertini
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la ministre
madame la rapporteur chers collègues le
projet de loi relatif à l'accélération
des procédures liées à la construction
de nouvelles installations nucléaires à
proximité de site nucléaire existant et
au fonctionnement des installations
existantes
constituent l'un des principaux piliers
de l'évolution de la stratégie
énergétique française notre pays la
France veut effectivement être la
première grande nation à sortir des
énergies fossiles sa stratégie repose en
premier lieu sur un important effort de
sobriété énergétique le plan mise en
oeuvre depuis cet automne visant à
réduire de 10% notre consommation
énergétique en deux ans et de 40% en
2050 on est la preuve mais au-delà de
cet effort de sobriété il nous faut
surtout dès à présent remplacer les
énergies fossiles qui constituent les
deux tiers de l'énergie consommée par
notre pays par le biais d'énergie bas
carbone le nucléaire répond à ce défi de
décarbonation et représente une énergie
garante de notre souveraineté
le présent projet de loi s'inscrit dans
cette démarche et prévoit des mesures
indispensables pour réunir les
conditions juridiques et financières et
d'organisation nécessaires à la relance
d'une politique ambitieuse en matière de
nucléaire civile en programmant 6
nouveaux operres 2 et l'étude de la
construction de 8 paires 2 additionnels
au terme de son examen en commission le
présent projet de loi a été enrichi par
l'adoption de 172 amendements tous les
amendements déposés par le groupe
horizon et apparentés au nombre de 12
ont été adoptés je me félicite de la
fluidité de nos échanges madame la
ministre mesdames les rapporteurs
mais revenons au texte et rien qu'aux
textes l'essentiel de ce projet sur
lequel nous allons débattre vise à
simplifier les démarches administratives
relatives au projet de nucléaires portés
à proximité immédiate ou concernant
directement des centrales existantes
certains travaux annexent comme le
défrichement terrassement station de
pompage bâtiment de traitement des
influents qui ne concernent jamais
directement l'îlot nucléaire pourront
débuter en amont permettant ainsi de
gagner jusqu'à 2 ans dans la
construction d'un nouveau réacteur
l'ensemble de cette démarche de
simplification et d'accélération des
procédures grâce à la superposition et
permis sans jamais renier le très haut
niveau d'exigence que nous portons à la
sûreté et la sécurité de notre filière
nucléaire à ce titre la fusion annoncée
de l'ASN et de l'IRSN a suscité ou peu
suscité des inquiétudes compréhensibles
mais je tiens à rappeler à cet instant
que le dispositif français de
réglementation de contrôle d'expertise
et de recherche en matière de sûreté
nucléaire et de radioprotection est
aujourd'hui structuré autour de deux
entités l'IRSN relève du statut
d'établissement public à caractère
industriel commercial sous tutelle de 5
ministères tandis que l'ASN relève du
statut d'autorité administrative
indépendante du gouvernement le statut
de l'ASM garantit un plus grand niveau
d'indépendance il exclut tout
interrogation sur l'interaction entre
les préoccupations de sûreté et de
radioprotection et d'autres objectifs
que le gouvernement doit aussi assumer
comme veiller à l'approvisionnement
énergétique ou jouer son rôle
d'actionnaire principal des grands
opérateurs du secteur nucléaire ces
dernières années ont démontré cette
indépendance avec pour exemple récent
les mises à l'arrêt de précaution des
réacteurs nucléaires dans un contexte où
la France perversé l'une des pires
crises énergétiques et tension
d'approvisionnement d'électricité de son
histoire les amendements que nous avons
soutenus adoptés en Commission visant
renforcer les moyens de l'ASM et
intégrer en son sein les compétences
techniques de l'URSS ce n'est pas une
une simple absorption de l'IRSN par la
SN mais une opération de fusion que je
qualifierais presque de création se
rapprochement permettra de fluidifier le
processus de décision et de gagner en
coordination les expertises techniques
pourront d'être présenté directement au
collège de l'ASM permettant ainsi des
décisions éclairées par la science plus
rapide qu'aujourd'hui en réduisant le
temps d'appropriation par la SN des avis
de l'URSS bien plus à destination de
l'ensemble des salariés de ces deux
entités le rapprochement de ces deux
structures se fera dans le respect de
leur statut respectifs de sorte que soit
tout autant préservé les conditions de
travail que le niveau de rémunération
dans un contexte par ailleurs de fortes
tensions sur les compétences dans la
filière l'attractivité des différents
métiers la composant sera d'ailleurs
renforcée à court terme compte tenu la
nécessité et de la nécessaire monter en
puissance des effectifs de contrôle de
la sûreté de la sécurité nucléaire cette
logique de renforcement de notre
dispositif de sûreté nucléaire et de
radioprotection permettra tout à la fois
une simplification et une meilleure
efficacité opérationnelle de la SN ce
faisant nous retirons aucune des
prérogatives de nos instances de
contrôle et nous assurons toutes les
précautions pour que soient séparées les
strates de décision et d'expertise afin
de garantir le plus haut niveau
d'indépendance à chaque étape
le groupe horizon apparenté tient à
saluer l'équilibre de ce texte présenté
par le gouvernement et les objectifs et
avancer qu'il comportent pour lequel
notre groupe a pris toute sa part en
complément la loi sur les énergies
renouvelables que nous avons adopté il y
a quelques semaines ce texte nous
permettra de mobiliser l'ensemble des
différences sources d'énergie bas
carbone pour atteindre l'objectif de
neutralité carbone que nous sommes
collectivement fixés et d'assurer la
souveraineté énergétique de la France je
vous remercie je vous remercie chers
collègues la parole est maintenant à
Madame Julie lernous
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mesdames les rapporteurs chers collègues
je suis une femme je ne suis pas
ingénieur du nucléaire je suis une
citoyenne qui s'interroge légitimement
sur un sujet sciemment confisqué par des
experts avec toujours des mots
rassurants nous vous inquiétez pas vous
ne connaissez pas le sujet mais tout est
sous contrôle vraiment le nuage de
Tchernobyl s'est arrêté à nos frontières
vraiment si Flamanville est un fiasco
industriel et financier c'est la faute
des Antilles nucléaires vraiment si la
moitié de nos réacteurs étaient à
l'arrêt cet été et qu'on a dû recourir
au charbon c'est là encore la faute des
antiprogressistes l'accumule
l'accumulation des déchets radioactifs
extrêmement dangereux pour des milliers
d'années ne pose pas de problème
le nucléaire c'est l'indépendance
énergétique de la France vraiment ne
sommes nous pas mains et point liés à la
Russie de Vladimir Poutine les débats du
nucléaire sont uniquement la faute des
écologistes vraiment les mêmes mots
depuis des décennies minimisant les
risques et brimant celles et ceux qui
posent des questions légitimes car oui
dans le pays le plus nucléarisé au monde
on est en droit de s'interroger en plus
de 50 ans l'industrie nucléaire n'a
résolu aucun des problèmes qu'elle était
censée résoudre dans ce contexte est-ce
raisonnable de décaler l'âge de départ à
la retraite de nos vieux réacteurs alors
qu'il souffre déjà de leur
vieillissement j'en veux pour preuve la
découverte nouvelle fissure d'une
ampleur inégalée sur les sites de Pandi
et 4 noms les défaillances graves
s'enchaînent et qui aurait pu prédire
Marcel Boiteux PDG d'EDF jusqu'en 1979
il expliqua que la longévité des
réacteurs a été calculée pour 12000
cycles thermiques soit un peu plus de 30
ans la corrosion sous contrainte n'est
donc pas un mauvais sort mais bien une
suite logique tu vieillissement des
centrales et nous voudrions parier sur
leur prolongation sans attendre la
validation de la SN nous ne sommes plus
en 1979 mais en 2023 est-ce vraiment
responsable de proposer une relance du
nucléaire sans prendre en compte la
réalité du changement climatique quand
on prévoit de construire de nouveaux
réacteurs n'est-il pas de notes devoir
d'étudier le contexte dans lequel ils
devront évoluer car s'ils arrivent à
voir le jour ce ne sera pas avant 15 ou
20 ans pourtant le climat s'emballe déjà
avec de plus en plus de sécheresse
comment continuer à prélever plus de 26
26 milliards de mètres cubes d'eau par
an sans impacter ni l'agriculture ni
notre consommation d'eau potable
le glacier apocalypse fond et fait
monter le niveau des mers ce n'est pas
de la science-fiction c'est la réalité
quid des sous centrales prévus en zone
submersible vous avez balayé tous nos
amendements ce sens en commission c'est
un acte grave et irresponsable d'autant
plus grave quand vous justifiez en
invoquant l'urgence climatique non le
nucléaire ne sauvera pas le climat tous
les scientifiques le Martel nous avons 7
ans pour agir alors que nos nouveaux
réacteurs s'ils voient le jour ne
verrons jour pas avant 2037 au plus tôt
vous masquez plutôt votre inaction
climatique derrière une soi-disant
solution magique qui n'est qu'un mirage
on ne sait même pas comment le financer
hausse d'impôts hausse des tarifs
piocher dans l'épargne des Français
aucune banque veut nous prêter de
l'argent pour une technologie aussi
hasardeuse je vous rappelle cela car le
texte sur lequel nous allons débattre a
profondément changé de nature et aura de
répercussions il n'était pas question de
la place d'un nouveau programme
nucléaire avez-vous insisté madame la
ministre mais aujourd'hui c'est bien de
ça dont il s'agit vous choisissez de
saboter notre objectif de réduction du
nucléaire pour mieux le relancer et cela
sans attendre les conclusions de
concertation sans apporter au Parlement
d'éléments sur la future loi de
programmation énergie climat qui je le
rappelle doit être publié d'ici juillet
2023 mais comme si ce mépris pour le
processus démocratique ne vous suffisait
pas vous comptez maintenant mettre à
terre notre modèle de sûreté pour que
rien n'entrave votre mégalom mégalomanie
atomique que l'on soit pour ou contre
l'énergie nucléaire notre intérêt le
même nous devons nous préserver le plus
possible d'un accident pourtant en deux
amendements vous actez à la hussarde le
démantèlement de l'IRSN ce choix de
ruiner dans la précipitation un système
dual robuste construit sur des décennies
et particulièrement irresponsable et
dangereux
je conclus pour vous dire que nous
sommes clairement inquiets par la
nouvelle teneur de ce texte c'est
atterré par votre volonté de passer en
force et d'imposer le fait accompli les
décisions sur l'avenir du nucléaire
seront lourdes conséquences et engage
les générations futures elle doit donc
pouvoir être arbitré de manière
démocratique et ne peuvent plus être
concentrés entre les mains de quelques
personnes qu'on soit un homme une femme
ingénieur du nucléaire ou pas laisser
enfin les citoyens conscients informés
éclairés décider de leur avenir prenez
notre opposition de résolution et
organiser une convention citoyenne sur
la relance du nucléaire je vous remercie
merci la parole est à Monsieur Sébastien
jumelles
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
président de commission madame la
rapporteur collègue
l'énergie est un bien commun un bien de
première nécessité nous en avons besoin
pour vivre nous déplacer pour faire
fonctionner le pays
dans cet esprit les questions liées à
son approvisionnement à son cou pour les
usagers dont les 8 millions de précaires
énergétiques mais aussi pour notre
économie réelle sont des questions
primordiales essentielles des questions
de souveraineté même dans le même temps
personne ne peut ignorer l'urgence
climatique qui bouscule non seulement
les équilibres vitaux de la planète mais
aussi nos modes de vie la lutte contre
le réchauffement climatique la réduction
des gaz à effet de serre
l'électrification des usages pour sortir
des énergies fossiles sont d'une urgence
telle
qu'ils impliquent d'établir enfin une
véritable stratégie nationale de
l'énergie du point de vue du groupe GDR
notamment de sa composante communiste
qui avec Marcel Paul ministre a battu le
feront industriel EDF GDF dans le sang
les larmes et l'espérance de la
Libération cela implique de sortir
l'énergie de la logique de marché du
dogme de la libéralisation construit à
l'échelle européenne par des
renoncements successifs de souveraineté
industrielle je l'ai dit en commission
aucun des gouvernements qui se sont
succédés ne peut s'exonérer de sa
responsabilité dans ce domaine de
Nicolas Sarkozy qui a privatisé EDF et
siphonné son modèle de financement avec
la loi Nome de Jospin avant mais de
Nicolas Sarkozy avec la reine en
favorisant d'une manière éhontée des
concurrents prédateurs en passant par
François Hollande enfermé dans un troc
politicien intenable donc incapable de
construire un mix énergétique équilibré
à Emmanuel Macron qui a fermé Fessenheim
puis consacrer l'abandon d'Astrid au
point d'être contraint de ré-offrir des
centrales thermiques après les avoir
lui-même fermé aucun n'est capable de
donner aucune leçon l'absence d'un état
stratège planificateur pèse lourd dans
la situation préoccupante d'aujourd'hui
les EnR se sont développés d'une manière
anarchique au gré du marché sont
structuration de filières industrielle
française au détriment des territoires
pour les Olympiens terrestres au
détriment des pêcheurs pour l'éolien en
mer la politique de steppengo a affaibli
nos savoir-faire le fiasco de
Flamanville les difficultés à faire face
efficacement aux corrosion sous
contrainte en sont les récentes
illustrations la crise énergétique que
nous traversons l'explosion des prix qui
fragilise non seulement nos artisans nos
boulangers mais aussi nos PME PMI aurait
dû vous conduire après le virage à 180
degrés opéré à Belfort à remettre les
choses à droit rompre la légende à
Bruxelles et la soumission à l'Allemagne
pour déconnecter le prix du gaz à la
construction du prix de l'énergie
réaffirmer la force de la puissance
publique avec une vraie nationalisation
de nos outils de production en même
temps que le rétablissement dans
l'urgence d'un vrai bouclier tarifaire
les tarifs réglementés organisés un vrai
débat démocratique autour d'un mix
énergétique et équilibré des carbonés
consentis parce qu'intelligent comme les
communistes ont porté dans les
différentes campagnes électorales de
Fabien Roussel afin bien gay en passant
par moi-même ensuite se doter des outils
pour atteindre ses objectifs en
réalisant un plan de rénovation
thermique en développant les EnR dans le
respect des territoires ou en relançant
une filière nucléaire avec un haut
niveau de recherche et de sûreté en
inversant le calendrier vous mettez un
coin dans cette logique en entachant
votre politique énergétique d'une
malformation congénitale le projet de
loi NR a laissé la part belle au marché
ce texte qui vient en débat alors que la
programmation pure annuelle de l'énergie
n'est pas réinterrogée pose question
comme pose question d'ailleurs la remise
en cause de l'originalité du modèle
français en matière de sûreté et de
sécurité je veux parler évidemment de la
fusion brutale de l'ISN et de la RSM le
député de Pandy vous le dit notre
rapport de confiance avec le nucléaire
n'est pas Béa naïf il est un rapport
exigeant d'un haut niveau de
revendication sociale et environnemental
que votre projet de fusion remet en
cause le député de panique vous dit que
notre rapport de confiance avec EDF
justifie notre attachement au statut des
électriciens gaziers en première ligne
contre la réforme des retraites et en
première ligne nécessaire pour renforcer
l'attractivité des métiers de l'énergie
notre rapport de confiance impose de
mieux encadrer la sous-traitance de
mieux anticiper les problématiques
posées par un chantier EPR en matière de
formation de santé d'aménagement du
territoire tel que les projets d'intérêt
nationaux en grignote du foncier vous le
savez
notre rapport de confiance pose en fait
la nécessité et nos amendements visent à
répondre à cela à réaffirmer le rôle
d'un état stratège planificateur garant
d'une énergie sûre décarbonée à bas coût
sous maîtrise publique voilà l'état
d'esprit qui animera le groupe GDR
durant tous ces débats je vous remercie
de votre attention merci la parole est
maintenant à Monsieur Benjamin sainte
huile
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre mesdames les rapporteurs
messieurs les présidents de commissions
mesdames Messieurs chers collègues
la question Antoine de fond qui n'est
pas posée mais à laquelle il faut
pouvoir répondre aujourd'hui pour les
semaines mois et année qui viennent
c'est quelle est la politique
énergétique espérée souhaitée préparer
par la France
nous le faisons dès à présent ici après
l'avoir fait sur les énergies
renouvelables sans que nous n'ayons fixé
le cadre et en cela la proposition qui
avait été portée par Madame Battistel
avait au moins le mérite de souligner à
quel point sur la méthode que vous avez
choisie nous sommes en désaccord et en
questionnement
finalement l'objectif que fixe le
gouvernement se résume par cette phrase
nous souhaitons que la France soit le
premier pays à sortir des énergies
fossiles en cela nous pouvons considérer
que l'objectif est à poursuivre et
espérer que chacun y trouve sa place
de ce fait nous sommes aujourd'hui
amenés à parler du nucléaire et de
l'accélération des procédures après que
nous ayons eu à travailler et à traiter
des énergies renouvelables
certains auront le loisir de redire ici
à la tribune que nous avons mis à
travers ce travail la charrue avant les
bœufs nous n'avons toujours pas compris
pourquoi vous choisissez ce calendrier
si ce n'est peut-être quelques craintes
de trouver ici dans cette hémicycle une
capacité à voter ce texte nous nous
tenons ardemment à cette loi de
programmation énergie et nous serons
attentifs à ce que le calendrier que
vous avez annoncé à plusieurs reprises
madame la ministre et en commission et
ici soit scrupuleusement respecté nous
avons acté le changement de pied du
président de la République à travers le
discours de Belfort et nous ne
rentrerons pas dans les débats stériles
autour de l'intérêt de savoir si le
changement de pied est utile et ceux qui
critiquent les changements de pieds ont
parfois tendance à eux aussi ou elles
aussi qu'elles ont changé d'avis il y a
quelques temps la réalité c'est que sur
la question complexe de l'énergie
nucléaire nous avons varié fluctuer
presque au même moment et au même niveau
que les opinions publiques et lorsque
nous faisons face à des accidents
nucléaires évidemment la question de la
sécurité passe devant et l'opinion
publique se pose la question de savoir
si nous sommes en capacité de faire
reculer cette énergie dangereuse et puis
dans les moments où les choses vont bien
ou dans les moments où l'énergie
nucléaire se confirme comme étant celle
qui peut répondre à un certain nombre de
interrogations alors effectivement
l'opinion publique y est très favorable
vous avez choisi les uns et les autres
de reprendre du coup ce chiffre de 75%
des Français qui sont favorables à
l'accélération de la part du nucléaire
en France très bien j'espère que le
gouvernement aura la cohérence de
toujours considérer l'opinion publique
avant de faire des choix de mesures
stratégiques sur la réforme des
retraites vous oubliez généralement de
citer de chiffres qui confirment
l'opposition nette de l'opinion publique
sur ce texte revenons donc à ce texte
qui passe par le petit chat de
l'aiguille qui ne pose pas la question
de la politique énergétique mais qui
revient uniquement à la question
initiale de l'accélération des
procédures
en cela le groupe liberté indépendant
outre-mer et territoires étaient très
attentifs et accompagnant de la
dynamique du texte initial qui a été
déposé par le Gouvernement mais il y a
un mais le travail qui a été porté par
le Sénat à insidieusement construit des
perspectives programmatiques qui nous
interrogent puisque nous avons à
considérer qu'une loi de programmation
interviendra prochainement et que donc
ces éléments programmatiques n'ont pas
leur place sauf que à ce petit jeu vous
avez choisi de faire votre marché et de
conserver ce qui vous intéressez en
l'occurrence c'est la doctrine rappelée
par la ministre panier renachée ni
plafond ni plancher je dois dire que là
encore nous ne comprenons pas que nous
ne prenions pas quelques mois pour
revenir au moment la loi de
programmation sur ce qui avait été fixé
dans les mandats et dans les Quincas
avec quelqu'un dans les quinquennat
précédent enfin je veux dire un mot des
questions de sûreté je le dis d'autant
plus tranquillement que je fais partie
des élus qui sont considérés pro
nucléaires ce qui veulent accélérer les
procédures doivent considérer à quel
point l'accélération peut engendrer une
crainte sur la question de la sûreté et
le message qui est envoyé à travers la
fusion de l'IRSN et de la SN c'est un
contre message pour celles et ceux qui
veulent porter la filière nucléaire nous
ferons en sorte de préenter comme
d'autres des amendements de suppression
parce qu'il envoie un contre message
nous défendrons par ailleurs un principe
non régression sur la sûreté nucléaire
parce que si nous voulons pouvoir
accélérer nous voulons le faire dans la
cohérence s'envoyer de sans envoyer de
contre messages à celles et ceux qui
légitimement s'inquiètent de savoir si
ça n'est pas au détriment de notre santé
je vous remercie je vous remercie la
parole est maintenant à Monsieur
Stéphane travers
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le président de la commission
des affaires économiques madame la
rapporteur même la rapporteur pour avis
et chers collègues cela fait des années
que la filière nucléaire est en proie au
doute et attend des pouvoirs publics de
construire un chemin nouveau pour le
développement et la confiance de toute
une filière composée d'hommes et de
femmes techniciens et ingénieurs à qui
je veux en ce moment témoigner de notre
soutien et de notre confiance nous
sommes ici pour examiner un texte
important qui permettra d'accélérer les
procédures liées à la construction de
nouvelles centrales la filière nucléaire
est une filière d'excellence qui depuis
de nombreuses années a connu la défiance
politique a été déconsidérée créant
ainsi un déficit d'image un déficit des
recrutements un déficit de monter en
compétences un déficit de transmission
des savoirs
ces atermoiements mes chers collègues
nous coûteront cher car depuis la fin
des années 90 jusqu'en 2007 aucune
centrale ne sera construite départ en
retraite ou vers d'autres filières le
savoir-faire se perd et c'est dans ses
conditions de faiblesse de la filière
que débutera la construction de l'EPR 3
de Flamanville tête de série et qui à
force de retard ne sera achevée
définitivement qu'en début 2024 nous
devons donc remédier à cela le discours
de Belfort du président de la République
a réaffirmé bien évidemment cette
ambition de faire de la France le
premier grand pays à sortir des énergies
fossiles avec la construction de six
nouveaux réacteurs le nucléaire énergie
décarbonée avec la construction de six
nouveaux réacteurs est un atout pour la
France nous avons été nombreux à saluer
cet engagement politique très fort
d'Emmanuel Macron pour l'émergence d'une
filière modernisée et qui contribue
ainsi
l'émergence et à l'image des
savoir-faire français le nucléaire est
la première source de production et de
consommation d'électricité le parc
français le plus puissant au monde après
celui des États-Unis c'est aussi un
modèle reconnu en matière de sûreté et
de sécurité alors que la guerre en
Ukraine a provoqué la flambée des prix
du mégawattheure et 1000 Europe sous
tension eDF n'a jamais aussi peu produit
en 2022 du fait des arrêts pour
maintenance c'est plus récemment de
problèmes de corrosion sous contrainte
près de la moitié des 56 réacteurs ont
été immobilisés à un moment où nous
avions tant besoin de produire de
l'électricité grâce à l'énergie
nucléaire il conviendra rappeler que la
France a longtemps disposé d'un des plus
bas prix de l'électricité et qui plus
est décarbonée la relance de notre
filière elle est indispensable pour
garantir notre souveraineté énergétique
et c'est pourquoi nous devons moderniser
d'abord le parc français et permettre
ainsi l'électrification des usages et
des carbon notre mix énergétique
aujourd'hui la construction d'une
centrale est soumise à de nombreuses
formalités nous devons donc ici
permettre d'accélérer la production de
nouvelles centrales en simplifiant
certaines procédures tout en
garantissant la sûreté et la sécurité
des installations on ne modifiant pas
les procédures rattachées à la
délivrance des autorisations aujourd'hui
nécessaires
anticiper le démarrage des travaux qui
ne revêt aucun caractère sensible créer
des procédures spécifiques permettant de
qualifier les projets de réacteurs
nucléaires de projets d'intérêt général
par décret et mettre les documents
d'urbanisme en compatibilité avec le
projet dispenser des projets de
construction de permis de construire
sécuriser juridiquement le développement
de réacteurs en bord de mer en
inscrivant dans le droit une dérogation
à la loi littorale pour les
installations nucléaires de base
supprimer enfin les dispositions du code
de l'environnement qui prévoit qu'un
réacteur est réputé fermé
dès lors qu'il a cessé de fonctionner
pendant plus de deux ans des
modifications ont été apportées en
commission des affaires économiques
après le travail des sénateurs en
première lecture et notamment à la
demande du gouvernement d'introduire des
dispositions législatives permettant la
fusion de l'ASN et l'IRSN mais aussi la
suppression de la disposition qui
prévoit que les collectivités font
parvenir leur observation au préfet sur
la mise en compatibilité ce texte doit
nous permettre de ne plus faire fi des
enjeux climatiques et des enjeux de
l'indépendance énergétique qui nous font
face et de la nécessité de reconstruire
notre souveraineté je sais les
désaccords qui peuvent nous opposer je
les respecte pour autant ce débat il va
mériter du fond de l'exigence de
l'absence d'approximation et de ne pas
convoquer les peurs comme cela pu être
fait parfois lors de la séance de la
Commission un milliard d'euros est
réservé pour la filière par le président
dans le plan France 2030 pour construire
des mini-réacteurs madame la ministre je
veux saluer votre écoute et votre
engagement pour faire en sorte que nous
puissions trouver les voies et écrire la
nouvelle page de la filière faite de
confiance et qui garantira aussi sur nos
territoires une exigence de sécurité et
de sûreté et de transparence des
installations que nous devons à
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens merci de
votre attention Philippe je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur
Jean-Philippe Tanguy
merci
madame la présidente madame la ministre
madame la rapporteur monsieur le
Président chers collègues le groupe
rassemblement national ne va pas cacher
sa satisfaction de constater sa totale
victoire idéologique sur la relance de
la filière nucléaire pendant des années
cet assemblée à l'acception notable des
communistes et des républicains a été
soumise au pire obscurantisme possible
préférant de son propre aveu la
sorcellerie à l'ingénierie nucléaire
enfin une majorité de force politique
revient dans le corps de la raison
bienvenue à vous je ne reviendrai pas
sur l'état déplorable de notre filière
nucléaire dans lequel trente ans de
dérive et d'erreurs laissent les
gouvernements en particulier depuis
qu'Emmanuel Macron est entré en
politique les Français ont tout vu ils
tireront d'eux-mêmes les conséquences
pour leur futur choix électoraux nous
choisissons d'aller de l'avant et de
soutenir toutes les mesures qui évitent
le pire animé comme toujours par le seul
intérêt national
néanmoins je ne voudrais pas mon plaisir
d'entendre madame la rapporteur mode
braision dont je vous salue la qualité
du travail avec le président kasbariian
affirmé que la relance du nucléaire que
nous devons opérer pour réindustrialiser
la France améliorer le niveau de vie des
Français et réussir la transition
énergétique doit s'apparenter à un
nouveau plan Messmer pendant la campagne
présidentielle la macronie n'avait pas
de mots assez dur quand nous annonçons
un vrai plan Messmer 2 que nous avions
appelé Marie Curie en hommage à la plus
grande scientifique que notre pays est
eu l'honneur de compter car en renouant
avec la filière nucléaire la France
renoue avec son destin depuis sciences
scientifique humaniste et promotéenne
vous avouez ne plus vouloir persévérer
dans l'erreur reste à savoir s'il s'agit
encore de belles paroles car pour le
moment vos actes restent bien faibles et
parfois contradictoires la fin du
mensonge d'état des 50% de production
nucléaire dans notre mix électrique est
un premier pas mais le choix de lancer
seulement 6 plus huit réacteurs d'ici
2050 ne permet ni de produire assez
d'électricité ni de rebâtir une filière
industrielle forte et durable ce
gouvernement fait malheureusement encore
les choses à l'envers dans un vrai plan
de filière le droit les moyens
techniques les ressources humaines
doivent toutes être mises au service
d'objectifs industriels précis et défini
en amont or nous discutons encore d'un
texte sans que ces objectifs aient été
justement fixés puisque nous sommes
encore sous les contraintes et la
tutelle d'une programmation
pluriannuelle de l'énergie qui prévoit
toujours la fermeture de 12 réacteurs
nucléaires
vos perspectives de consommation pour
2050 sont irréalistes avec des ambitions
de sobriété irrationnelles qui ne sont
que des futurs pénuries pour les
Français vous n' ambitionnez pas
d'augmenter plus de 1 à 2 points la part
de l'industrie dans le PIB pour 2050 or
les importations industrielles
représentent 50% de l'empreinte carbone
de la France sans relatalisation il n'y
aura pas de prospérité pour la France
mais il n'y aura pas non plus du respect
des engagements de Paris auxquels vous
tenez tant seul le rassemblement
national prend et propose des mesures
pour relocaliser au moins 10 points
d'industrie dans notre pays B vous
restez en fait prisonnier des dogmes qui
nous ont conduit à des catastrophes à la
catastrophe vous continuez à utiliser le
rapport RTE comme une bible alors que la
première ministre a reconnu sous serment
que ces mêmes rapports s'étaient trompés
sur toute la ligne pendant 20 ans vous
continuez de croire qu'il ne faut pas
opposer renouvelable et nucléaire mais
la complémentarité entre le nucléaire
l'hydraulique les steppes et l'hydrogène
est évidente c'est même le pilier de
notre plan Marie Curie en revanche nous
contestons le développement massif des
énergies intermittentes qui sont
tellement contraires au bon
fonctionnement du couple nucléaire
hydraulique que vous devez changer la
priorité d'accès au réseau module en nos
réacteurs et vous retrouvant sans autre
ressources que le charbon et le gaz
quand il n'y a ni vent ni soleil
j'attends toujours de savoir quel est
votre solution technique quand il n'y a
ni vent ni soleil en hiver pour
atteindre la neutralité carbone
aussi je vous demande de prendre enfin
en considération nos propositions s'il
faut lancer le programme de PR2 il ne
faut aucun chronique nucléaire nous
maintenant qu'il faut lancer dès
maintenant des EPR sur la base des
retours d'expérience acquis des
chantiers actuels britanniques il faut
relancer immédiatement le programme
Astrid et ses projets satellites pour
rendre opérationnel un réacteur
commercial de génération 4 pour 2040
vous devez accepter de rouvrir le
dossier Fessenheim abandonner cette
fierté mal placée aujourd'hui nous
savons que vous avez comme une erreur la
France ne peut se permettre de sacrifier
cet outil industriel qui peut être
relancé pour 60 à 80 ans démontrant la
faisabilité pour l'ensemble de notre
parc accepter notre proposition de
lancer massivement la cogénération
nucléaire une solution qui permettra de
réindustrialiser la France avec une
chaleur urbaine peu chère il est
ahurissant que nos amendements étaient
rejetés enfin il faut relancer en
urgence les steppes et l'optimisation de
mobara de nos barrages chers collègues
vous avez été la majorité qui a mis
notre filière nucléaire dans la pire
rapatrie l'occasion historique vous est
donnée d'en sortir la France ne peut se
permettre de la gâcher s'il vous plaît
ne la gâchez pas
je vous remercie la parole est
maintenant à Monsieur Maxime Lainé
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre mesdames les rapporteurs chers
collègues de Gaulle est mort c'était au
20e siècle et comme le nucléaire je
doute qu'il puisse incarner notre avenir
c'est pourtant ainsi que ce rêve le
président Macron prêt à tous les
passages en force pour assouvir ses
caprices comme un atteste ce nouveau
projet de loi un passage en force qui
s'inscrit dans un calendrier abscon en
janvier le Parlement adopté une loi sur
les énergies renouvelables qui les
freinent plus qu'il ne les encourage par
ce texte vous prévoyez la construction
de 14 réacteurs une relance du nucléaire
qui passerait par des technologies de
type EPR 2 dont l'ingénierie n'est
toujours pas abouti ou SMR qui sont
aujourd'hui à l'état de prototype et qui
s'accompagnerait de la prolongation
décentrales existantes de 10 20 ou 30
ans en même temps ces tenu un débat
public sur la construction de nouveaux
réacteurs à panli impossible à terminer
sereinement puisqu’entre temps le
monarque avait tacté la relance de
l'atome dans un Conseil de politique
nucléaire à sa main pendant que le Sénat
détricoté l'actuel PPE en préamtant les
débats à venir sur la prochaine loi de
programmation énergie climat mais après
une concertation sur le mix énergétique
confidentielle un alibi dont les
conclusions ont été rendues la semaine
dernière ce texte impose d'abord un coup
de force réglementaire avec un seul
objectif permettre au président de
couper le ruban du chantier d'une
centrale avant la fin de son mandat
recentralisation des procédures
d'urbanisme contournement des procédures
environnementales et de participation du
public le Conseil d'État a pourtant
estimé que le gain de temps espéré par
ces mesures dérogatoires ne peut être
évaluée avec certitude pire au détour
d'un amendement gouvernemental ce texte
impose un passage en force sur la sûreté
nucléaire avec le projet de
démantèlement de l'IRSN sans la moindre
étude d'impact il est pourtant essentiel
de maintenir notre système dual qui
sépare recherche expertise d'une part
contrôle et décision d'autre part nous
sommes particulièrement inquiets d'un
potentiel changement de doctrine dans la
pression du risque il faut rappeler que
le nucléaire repose sur un certain
nombre de mythes et son éventuel relance
sur des paris risqués il y a d'abord
pour le mythe de la souveraineté
l’uranium ne pousse pas dans nos jardins
il nous vient de pays comme le Niger ou
le Kazakhstan en passant par la Russie
il y a ensuite le mythe d'une énergie
pas chère flamant ville 3 toujours pas
en service est un véritable gouffre
financier dont le budget a été multiplié
par 6 les mesures de ce texte sont
estimées à 250 milliards d'euros mais
qui peut dire de combien cette facture
sera multipliée et qui la paiera le
mythe d'une technologie parfaitement
maîtrisée alors que personne aurait vu
venir les problèmes de corrosion sous
contrainte 26 réacteurs ont dû être
arrêté cet hiver nous faisons risquer le
blackout pire les fissures profondes
découvertes à panly et ailleurs ces
derniers jours conduisent EDF à vérifier
en urgence plus de 200 soudures qui peut
affirmer que les réacteurs nouveaux ne
connaîtront pas les mêmes problèmes que
dire également du mythe d'une énergie
propre les centrales déverses
quotidiennement des éléments radioactifs
dans nos cours d'eau les tâches de
maintenance exposent nécessairement les
agents au rayonnement comment expliquer
d'ailleurs que 80% de ces doses soient
réservées aux sous-trait l'adjectif
propre ne colle pas davantage et une
industrie qui produit chaque année des
milliers de tonnes de déchets
radioactifs pour lesquels il n'existe
toujours aucune solution alors que nos
capacités d'entreposage sont déjà
arrivés à leur limite que ferons-nous de
milliers de tonnes de déchets
supplémentaires enfin il y a toujours le
risque d'accident que nous devrions tous
avoir à l'esprit alors que nous
commémorons le triste anniversaire de la
catastrophe de Fukushima combien de
pilules diodes devront nous encore
distribuer dans le périmètre des
centrales ce risque d'accidents
nucléaire est évidemment décuplé dans un
monde en guerre comme nous le rappelle
en ce moment même la centrale de
zaporigia en Ukraine si tu es non loin
de celle de Tchernobyl dont le cœur
brûle depuis 37 ans qu'on entend ou non
ces arguments il faut admettre que ni
nos besoins énergétiques de moyen terme
ni la lutte indispensable contre le
réchauffement climatique ne pourront
être résolus par la relance nucléaire
alors que le GIEC nous donne trois ans
pour baisser nos émissions de gaz à
effet de serre ce sont 15 ans au bas mot
qui nous sépare du premier
kilowatt-heure
produit par le premier nouveau réacteur
par ailleurs alors que le pompage pour
les centrales représente déjà le
deuxième poste de consommation en eau
dans notre pays quand sera-t-il dans le
cadre d'un scénario d'augmentation des
températures à 4 degrés on le voit la
relance de l'atome est clairement
climato schizophrène le sixième rapport
du GIEC
insiste sur la nécessité d'options
financièrement accessible et rapide à
déployer ce dont le nucléaire est
incapable un scénario 100%ouvelable
n'est pas une toupie mais une nécessité
à condition d'avoir d'abord le courage
d'un grand débat sur la sobriété nous
refusons donc de donner un blanc saint
au délire jupitérien à doubé dans une
grande communion par la minorité
présidentielle la droite et le
rassemblement national nous affirmons au
contraire qu'il est urgent de planifier
démocratiquement une sortie raisonnée et
maîtrisée du nucléaire pensez avec les
salariés pour l'ensemble de ces raisons
nous voterons contre ce projet de loi
je vous remercie de la parole est à
Monsieur Olivier Marleix
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la ministre
enfin l'Assemblée nationale va se
prononcer sur un texte de relance du
nucléaire enfin la France va reprendre
le fil de cette histoire écrite par le
général de Gaulle d'aide à Libération
pour doter le pays des moyens de son
indépendance énergétique longtemps le
nucléaire a faible dans notre pays
l'objet d'un consensus national il le
doit générale de Gaulle mais il le doit
aussi à Frédéric Joliot prix Nobel de
chimie premier commissaire à l'énergie
atomique Prix Lénine n'aurait plus
ajouter la France avait raté les deux
premières révolutions industrielle faute
d'énergie fossile en quantité suffisante
charbon ou gaz le nucléaire nous a
offert une énergie abondante propre et
bon marché et puis et puis vient la
rupture dans cette ambition nucléaire en
2012 le président François Hollande a
sacrifié ce consensus en décidant de
réduire la part du nucléaire à 50% de
notre production d'électricité
fois 50%, il ne s'agit sans doute pas
d'autre chose qu'une poire électorale
coupée en deux sur un coin de table avec
les verres mais c'est bien sous la
présidence d'Emmanuel Macron que les
décisions les plus fatales à la filière
nucléaire ont été prises décisions de
fermer 14 réacteurs en novembre 2018
alors que Jean-Martin folle savait remis
à Nicolas Hulot Hulot et à Bruno Le
Maire un rapport 3 mois plutôt seulement
invitant le gouvernement à saisir
l'urgence de construire 6 nouveaux eprs
abandon du projet Astrid le réacteur de
la quatrième génération vente de la
branche énergie d'Alstom à l'Américain
général électrique fermeture définitive
de Fessenheim en juin 2020 quel étrange
défaite nous renonçons au nucléaires
nous démobilisons toute la filière et
puis un beau jour de février 2022 à deux
mois d'élection présidentielle le
président Macron réalise un des plus
spectaculaires tête à que de notre
histoire politique il n'est plus
question de fermer 14 réacteurs mais
d'en construire 14 quel cirque chez le
groupe si notre groupe est évidemment
favorable à ce revirement de l'histoire
au nom de la souveraineté énergétique de
la France au nom de la compétitivité de
notre économie mais aussi au nom du
climat vous comprendrez madame la
ministre que nous sommes peu enclin à
faire une confiance aveugle à ceux qui
se sont le plus trompés je suis très
cinq principaux points de vigilance
d'abord votre méthode relève comme
relève comme toujours d'une politique de
gribouille vous nous proposez un texte
qui parle d'urbanisme de permis de
construire sans rien dire des besoins de
production nécessaire à notre pays dans
les 30 ou 40 prochaines années pourtant
on a tellement entendu le bras à RTS ces
dernières années pour lui faire dire ce
qu'on avait envie d'entendre que on
aurait pu commencer par cette nouvelle
programmation plus réelle de l'énergie
deux nous vous devons y voir clair sur
les choix technologiques le père de
Flamanville dont nous et revendique
confirmant la paternité à droite est un
prototype et force de constater qu'il ne
marche pas encore alors on nous parle
d'un opère 2 qui serait inspiré de des
modèles de Tashan mais on nous dit qu'il
faudra sans doute attendre un opère 3
pour être sur une version industrielle
quelle solution allez-vous retenir sur
cette question nous demandons donc un
rapport du gouvernement pour éclairer la
représentation nationale et je crois
aussi que le fils parlementaire
d'évaluation des choix scientifiques et
technologiques devraient être
régulièrement associé au choix qui
seront qui seront faits il en va de même
pour les SMS oui la France possède ce
savoir-faire que nous utilisons sur
notre porte-avions sur nos sous-marins
oui il y a une compétition mondiale pour
développer ces technologies mais
qu'elles sont précisément vos objectifs
en la matière l'exportation
l'alimentation électrique de sites
industriels
la production d'hydrogène on ne sait
encore rien de vos intentions il y a
aussi la question centrale de la
quatrième génération cette génération de
réacteurs à notre rapide qui a le tort
de priver les antinucléaires de leurs
principales argument puisqu'il utilise
les déchets nucléaires comme
combustibles l'arrêt de super Phénix a
été une première trahison celui d'Astrid
la seconde résoudre à la fois la
question du combustible et des déchets
est un enjeu formidable la quatrième
génération celle nucléaire durable et
puis il y a enfin la question du
financement du futur nucléaire c'est la
question de l'avenir d'EDF c'est la
question du tarif de la reine et de ce
qui succéderait à la reine il faut avoir
à l'égard du gouvernement la docilité du
président de la commission des affaires
économiques pour considérer que des
amendements sur ce sujet sont
irrecevables et seraient hors sujet par
rapport à notre débat c'est aussi la
question de la taxonomie l'exclusion du
nucléaire de la liste des énergies
utiles à la décarbonation de l'industrie
européenne est inacceptable pour la
France et doit être refusé par le
Président de la République
encore faudrait-il que vous en soyez
vous-même convaincu ce qui ne semble pas
être le cas puisque le label greenfin de
votre délivré par votre ministère exclut
lui-même les gens qui investissent dans
le nucléaire de de votre label madame le
ministre si nous méfions des nouveaux
convertis il y a beaucoup de chemin
encore pour passer de l'exercice de
communication au retour à la
souveraineté énergétique de notre pays
merci la parole est maintenant à Madame
Louise Morel
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le président de commission
madame la rapporteur chers collègues au
regard de l'actualité depuis un an avec
la guerre en Ukraine et toutes les
conséquences qu'elle entraîne dans
l'ordre mondial et dans la vie
quotidienne des Français notre
responsabilité la plus urgente et de
reprendre en main notre souveraineté
elle nous commande d'assurer à long
terme notre souveraineté énergétique
garante de nos libertés lors de l'accord
de Paris l'engagement a été pris de
limiter l'augmentation de la température
moyenne de la planète en dessous de 2
degrés par rapport au niveau
préindustriel tel doit être l'objectif
qui nous réunit au-delà de notre bord
politique concrètement cet engagement se
traduit par une maîtrise de notre
empreinte carbone à environ 2 tonnes de
CO2 par an par français d'ici 2050 nous
y sommes encore loin notre empreinte
carbone est actuellement de 8,9 tonnes
par an
ainsi pour arriver à tenir cet objectif
les efforts à entreprendre sont
conséquent la politique des petits
gestes n'est pas suffisante et nous
avons besoin d'une politique
volontariste en la matière afin de
respecter nos objectifs climatiques au
niveau du groupe démocrate nous
partageons la double exigence de la
nécessaire sobriété et de la
décarbonation de nos modes de vie la
sobriété est la mère des priorités mais
ce ne doit toutefois pas être une
sobriété sans technologie ou sans
innovation ni une sobriété qui menace
nos libertés individuelles d'autre part
une part incompressible de nos activités
nécessitent une consommation d'énergie
notre deuxième priorité est donc de la
décarboner pour ce faire la fin de notre
dépendance aux énergies fossiles et
l'électrification de nos usages sont
indispensables il en va également de
notre souveraineté économique
face à cette double exigence sobriété et
décarbonation nous devons collectivement
nous donner les moyens pour réussir nos
objectifs climatiques et les solutions
ne se comptent pas par milliers c'est
dans ce cadre-là que le groupe démocrate
accueille favorablement ce texte relatif
à l'accélération des procédures liées à
la construction de nouvelles
installations nucléaires et au
fonctionnement des installations
existantes il est la continuité de
l'action engagée depuis 2017 par le
gouvernement afin de se doter de tous
les outils pour remplir nos ambitions
climatiques je souhaite ici rappeler la
ligne politique du groupe démocrate sur
le sujet du nucléaire nous sommes
Proclima nous ne sommes pas dogmatiques
et nous avons bien conscience des
difficultés et interrogations légitimes
que pose le nucléaire mais nous sommes
pragmatiques sur les différents
scénarios proposés par RTE ceux qui sont
exclusivement composés d'énergie
renouvelables présentent bien trop
d'incertitudes quant à leur réel
achèvement aussi il est nécessaire
d'avoir une part de nucléaire dans notre
mix énergétique au sujet du fond de ce
texte nous nous accordons sur le fait
que l'extension des sites nucléaires
existants doit être facilité au maximum
le temps industriel étant suffisamment
long pour que les délais de construction
ne soient pas rallongés en raison de
difficultés administratives les mesures
proposées dans ce texte auront des
effets sur les délais de mise en service
et en conséquence sur le coup des futurs
réacteurs pour résumer notre ligne
directrice demeure l'accélération des
procédures partout où cela est possible
sans jamais rogner sur nos exigences en
termes de concertation et surtout de
sûreté sur ce dernier point il est une
chose essentielle que nous devons
souligner l'examen en commission de ce
texte a été marquée par l'adoption d'un
amendement réunissant les compétences de
l'Institut de radioprotection et de
sûreté nucléaires avec celle de
l'Autorité de Sûreté Nucléaire notre
groupe n'a pas apporté son soutien à
cette mesure au stade de la commission
regrettant en manque de temps et de
concertation et s'interrogeant sur la
pertinence de réunir les missions
d'expertise et de recherche avec celle
de décision au sein d'une même structure
la capacité d'écoute de Madame la
Ministre face à nos vigilances a permis
un débat apaisé et rationnel dans le
cadre à présent de l'examen de ce texte
dans l'hémicycle notre groupe propose
par voie d'amendements la création d'un
comité de suivi de cette réforme
composée de parlementaires afin de
veiller à ce que certains principes
soient respectés parmi lesquels le
maintien des compétences la séparation
des expertises et la garantie d'un
dialogue et d'une bonne information à
l'égard de la population pour conclure
ce texte ne sera vraisemblablement pas
l'unique occasion de parler du
développement du nucléaire en France
cette année nous avons également la PPE
qui arrive cet été mais il n'en demeure
pas moins que l'étude de du texte est un
signal fort envoyé à la filière du
nucléaire en France avec lui il écrit
notre volonté de retrouver l'outil et la
culture industrielle nécessaire à la
réussite de grands projets nucléaires
afin de lancer le chantier industriel de
ce siècle il est nécessaire d'avoir une
cape un cap une vision et une
détermination claire le groupe
démocratique est engagé et notre main ne
tremblera pas en votant en faveur de ce
texte je vous remercie je vous remercie
d'avoir été à Madame Emmanuelle Ménard
madame la présidente Madame le Ministre
madame le rapporteur chers collègues
évoqué la question du nucléaire français
c'est parler d'une vision mais aussi
d'un fiasco en cela vous avez raison
madame le rapporteur quand vous dites
que ce n'est pas on se refilant la
patate chaude concernant l'état de la
filière qu'on fera avancer le débat mais
tout de même
la commission d'enquête en cours sur la
perte de souveraineté et d'indépendance
énergétique de la France montre d'ores
et déjà combien les politiques publiques
ont manqué en la matière de clairvoyance
d'ambition et de courage personne n'a
rien vu personne ne se souvient de rien
mais tout le monde savait dommage pour
les Français qui payent chaque jour au
prix fort une errance faite d'idéologie
de plus ilanimité d'un terme amont de
compromission et j'ose le dire de
veulerie et cela dure depuis 30 ans
faut-il égrainer ici la litanie des
décisions désastreuses qui ont conduit
la France à la situation dans laquelle
elle se trouve il y a encore 20 ans et
grâce au plan Messmer EDF était le
champion mondial du nucléaire la France
bénéficiait d'une électricité parmi les
moins chères du monde et de plus une
énergie décarbonée là où nous aurions dû
aujourd'hui engrager engrangé des super
profits il ne nous reste que des pertes
records 19,7 milliards d'euros en 2022
l'arrêt en 1997 de super Phénix sans
concertation et pour des motifs plus ou
moins valables fut le premier coup porté
à notre souveraineté énergétique non
seulement l'arrêt de ce programme a
coûté une fortune mais il a mis un terme
à des années de recherche et de
savoir-faire dans le retraitement et
l'utilisation des déchets il était
l'avenir du nucléaire et nous l'avons
bradé
puis ce fut autour de Nicolas Sarkozy et
de Jean-Louis Borloo d'expliquer que la
France n'avait pas besoin de nouvelles
EPR
Vartan suite François Hollande et son
mix énergétique avant d'accueillir
Nicolas Hulot pour lequel le nucléaire
était une folie là je ne parle pas de la
fermeture de Fessenheim décidé par
François Hollande est mise en œuvre par
Emmanuel Macron ni de la mise à mort
programmée du projet Astrid de toute
évidence un immense gâchis en février
2022 le président de la République a
annoncé à grand renfort de communication
un vaste plan de relance avec la
construction de 6 voire de 14 réacteurs
de dernière génération d'ici à 2050 une
bonne nouvelle qui ne peut rester à
l'état d'annonce il est urgent d'agir et
en cela le texte que nous examinons
aujourd'hui va dans le bon sens dans le
bon sens parce qu'il est le témoin de
cette volonté de facilitation mais je ne
peux que m'interroger sur la méthode
pourquoi dissocier énergie renouvelables
nucléaire et programmation pluriannuelle
de l'énergie pourquoi cette méthode du
saucissonnage qui nous empêche d'avoir
une vision d'ensemble indispensable pour
assurer notre souveraineté énergétique
et supprimer les articles
programmatiques introduit par les
sénateurs n'a pas de quoi nous rassurer
même chose pour l'objectif de 0
artificialisation des sols qu'il nous
faut évidemment continuer de mettre en
oeuvre tout en protégeant non seulement
le développement de notre énergie
nucléaire mais plus généralement le
déploiement de gigafactory d'envergure
nationale capable de développer par
exemple de l'hydrogène bas carbone
par ailleurs votre texte reste muet sur
l'impact des décisions européennes sur
la dépendance énergétique de la France
entre le marché européen de l'énergie et
le mécanisme absurde de l'accès régulé à
l'électricité nucléaire historique la
reine nous sommes devenus les idiots
utiles de l'énergie européenne il est
urgent d'en sortir c'est la
compétitivité de la France qui est en
jeu en témoigne les récents blocages de
l'Union européenne en particulier avec
l'Allemagne et l'Espagne sur l'hydrogène
bas carbone produit à partir du
nucléaire qui pour l'instant n'est pas
inclus dans la directive européenne
révisée sur les énergies renouvelables
nous avons les capacités de nous
relancer dans la course au nucléaire
neutrons rapide seul fondu fusion
nucléaire ces alternatives existent pour
rendre l'énergie atomique encore plus
sûr et que dire de quelques florons
Français de pointe comme Jimmy énergie
Marea transmutex Renaissance fusion ou
genevia à Béziers dans le domaine de
l'hydrogène des carbone et justement
ce projet de loi peut être une seconde
chance pour notre nucléaire Jean-Bernard
Lévy aux commandes d'EDF de 2014 à 2022
déplorait on n'a pas embauché des gens
pour construire des centrales on a
embauché des gens pour enfermer 12 alors
il est plus que temps d'inverser la
vapeur si j'ose dire en espérant bien
naturellement qu'il ne soit pas trop
tard je vous remercie
je vous remercie la discussion générale
et close et donc j'appelle maintenant
dans le texte de la commission les
articles du projet de loi
ah Monsieur laporteur vous voulez
prendre la parole parce que ça m'a pas
été indiqué vous avez la parole monsieur
le président
oui mais merci madame la Présidente je
voulais profiter de cette intense de cet
instant pour faire une réponse et une
remarque une réponse à monsieur le
Président Marleix qui a parlé de ma
docilité sur la question de la
recevabilité des amendements
il se trouve monsieur le Président
Marleix que vous avez souhaité à
l'occasion de ce texte refaire le débat
de la reine et que j'ai considéré en
commission des affaires économiques il
n'y avait pas de lien direct ou indirect
avec les amendements que vous portiez et
le texte en question
il se trouve que monsieur le Président
d'Alex monsieur le Président Marleix que
vous comptiez ma responsabilité en
commission à la limite ça fait partie du
jeu tous les groupes viennent
régulièrement pour dire je conteste la
rentabilité il se trouve que vous avez
redéposé les mêmes amendements à la
séance et que la séance a eu exactement
le même jugement c'est-à-dire qu'elle a
considéré que c'était cavalier donc
l'analyse est exactement la même
j'ajoute que votre groupe portait un
amendement que j'ai à titre personnel
déclaré recevable en commission qui est
celui de notre collègue Julien Dib sur
la suppression de la CNDP il se trouve
que je trouvais qu'il y avait un lien
indirect avec le texte bon et en
commission des affaires économiques je
l'ai rendu recevable bon il se trouve
que la séance n'a pas eu le même avis
vous avez redéposé le même amendement et
la séance a décidé que ce n'était pas
recevable donc vous voyez plutôt que de
remettre en cause mon appartient sur la
recevabilité vous aurez pu me remercier
de la mancheétitude que dont j'ai fait
part et dont j'ai fait preuve en
commission vis-à-vis des amendements du
groupe LR j'ai toujours agi avec
honnêteté et indépendance sur le sujet
et je trouve un peu de votre part
monsieur le Président marlex de remettre
en cause mon indépendance sur le sujet
je profite de cet instant pour apporter
une réponse plus sur le fond sur la
question de la légitimité démocratique
de ce texte puisque j'ai entendu notre
collègue madame laarnous écologiste
remettre en cause le fait que nous
passions par un projet de loi pour
accélérer la création de nouveaux
réacteurs et que il aurait été
préférable de passer par référendum je
crois que sur ce débat nous avons tous
ici une part de légitimité populaire
nous avons tous abordé lors de nos
campagnes législatives la question du
nucléaire nous avons tous exprimé des
positions assez claires pour certains
aussi le nucléaire pour d'autres
favorables à la création de nouveaux
central et je trouve curieux que des
parlementaires remettent en cause
l'indépendance du Parlement le pouvoir
du Parlement et la légitimité
démocratique de cette enceinte en
considérant que seul un passage par
référendum permettrait de valider des
choix démocratiques ça n'est pas le cas
les Français ont été consultés quatre
fois en 2022 ce sujet-là était large
ment débattu et nous avons tous ici une
part de légitimité à aborder et porter
assumer revendiquer des positions
politiques y compris sur la question du
nucléaire je vous remercie mesdames la
président